mon ordi qui
n'était pas content je crois surchargé
s'est mis en écran bleu et on est de
retour ont déroulé de retour ne
m'inquiétais pas au nom vous a pas
abandonnés
d'ailleurs j'ai grossi d'un coup je
crois à ses fans ouais je vais tendre de
jeu de faire le pas
j'ai plus trop de cheveux ça ça mérite
qu'on le fasse remarquer c'est bien je
vais je vais essayer de remédier à ça
mais en tout cas vous avez vu bah il a
eu raison s'accrochait liam sign
puisqu'il a réussi à retirer à un petit
quelque chose de sa position et quand
vous acquittez marie charon apporte lui
a filé lui a redonné la pièce et ils
sont donc fait faire un jeu nul
pas pu
et donc on est revenus désole un jus un
problème d'ordinateur avec écran bleu
donc
je vais essayer de changer
kevin a qui effectivement a grossi
qu'allons nous faire remarquer
et aura le droit
à une petrov on a la structure
caractéristiques en tout cas
et du coup la position position noir
comment ça peut être sympa on pourrait
imaginer que les blancs font la paire de
fumay sont leur père reçoit un peu
coincé à fives et noir peuvent peut-être
d'avancer tous leurs pions et vos biens
ni à la sarine faire quelque chose comme
ça
parce que si fed à merci cges un qui va
contraindre les deux fous les deux fous
sap est très très facile cette histoire
donc peut-être pour ça que tout à
l'heure ils avaient tous ces quatre
aussi un rapport pour
pour éviter justement cette position de
ville de
petrov là on a parlé un oui parce que
total a c'est vrai qu'il a joués
pandaria il a joué ici en fait poussé
quatre accablant pour empêcher du coup
le cavaliere trois cavaliers
investisseurs
alors
j moment et il doit avoir mal avec ce
qui vient de se passer à la partie
précédente aussi
alors j'ai pas vu du goût ce qui s'est
passé et il a rendu une pièce comme
comme ça nous arrive sur quelques points
comme c'était assez moche
il s'est pris un petit bain et la bac
les deux cavaliers se souvenait il
aurait attaqué à et donc du coup le
cavalier soutien a disparu bon c'est
cool parce que le conte sera pour moi un
humain parce que enfin ça c'est quelque
chose que nous ont fait
en face le ccc ccc très difficile à moi
je pense que d'un problème que moi je
n'étais pas
complètement sûr surtout que j'ai pas
ton expérience en stream ces pannes et
du coup quand j'ai créé mes premières
parties la sueur sur chaise comme en
bois instruments autant en dix minutes
aucun problème que le fai n'y a pas il
n'y a pas trop de soucis mais en trois
minutes c'est vrai que c'est chaud c'est
chaud donc ça ça arrive à tout le monde
et niasse a réuni les raisons de
s'accrocher non c'est très dur un très
très dur moi je de mode dans une pièce
sur pièce un
bois tout le monde oui mais voilà donc
du coup c'est vrai que c'est difficile
de finir une partie 1 quand on est
gagnant généralement le plus difficile
c'est de gagner une partie de gérer son
temps rex là en plus
aidé pense que c'est en voulant gérer
son temps c'est vrai de ce souci là tu
sais que tu veux bien faire que gère ton
temps pour gagner avec ta pièce en plus
par exemple tu joues un coup trop vite
et alors qu redonne les chances et voilà
c'est parti
à pied au c la pression du match qui
joue pas parce que cette partie tu la
donnes à richard rapport à n'importe
quel
bliss de
standards il va la gagner mais là je
pense qu'après soient-ils match tout ça
bon ces femmes qui jouent différemment
en
était pas témoin impliqué mais c'est que
tu es tu as l'impression en fait la
pression dans certains pièges téléphone
et je vais vendre ou essaient de
donc ok position à l'arrêt dans l'air
ont lâché dans ce malgré la perte de fou
blanche a préféré les noirs puisque la
position est la plus lisible on vous
voit les pièces qui peuvent passer sur
le sur les leroy ou du coup c'est quand
même plus agréable la paire de formuler
un peu et ce côté blanc
dans s'éclairant ce musée nobel lui
perdu quand tu blesses généralement tu
préfères les productions de batac parce
que c'est vraiment ça se joue là dessus
sur les tactiques moi dira le parti
plutôt que je professionnel allende
leeds et du coup on voit les blade et
espoirs peuvent facilement arriver sur
sur le roi blanc donc c'est vrai que les
remous ciel ya g3 qui bon maintenant un
grand g iii qui est rangé 3 c'est pas
maintenant mais c'est des choses qui
peuvent arriver plus tard
monsieur les rocades
donc hors que le projet veut c'est hyper
intéressant un rapport qui met droit
sans tache blanche donc les bases
blanche parce que les noirs ont un fou
de cases noires du patient case blanche
on voit qu'ils apprennent beaucoup
d'anticipation chez les dodgers qui
savent que ça peut tourner plus tard il
soit à lapproche barbu d'une minute
chacun et ça peut du coup ouvriers ouais
donc sa lutte qu'ils mènent d'un point
comme l'instant par rapport à nos
pronostics on avait donné
enfin pensez que
sarine pouvait être favori dans ce match
malgré malgré parmi les points et donc
c'est
ce que sur le papier que richard
rapporte m 27 70 c'est quand même un
gros poisson quoi oui mais moi
sarine en bits c'est très fort le
makossa sarba un petit peu les cartes
ouais sarine il a 17 ans en blitz bon à
l'époque qui fait que ça nous et sur
pièce comme une zombie chess h 24 min
des geeks et les bullet vont c'est
vraiment alors sur internet en oublie ça
c'est vraiment son domaine quoi
oui et en plus cela il a eu quand même
pas mal de réussite si on prend la
partie précédente
normalement il devrait y avoir un score
beaucoup plus neutre
s'il perdait cette égalité des coûts
exacts
donc je pense
ok c'est mon avis hein mais je pense que
que en bullet
sarine devrait plus fort c'est mon avis
et je pense que du coup richard rapport
devrait essayer de
s'il veut gagner le match je pense faire
la différence en cinq plus une ou en 38
donc là on prétend te tue le suspense
était en train de dire que finalement
c'est quasiment plié c'est ça
si sa in fine la portion de sicile avec
ben écoute je pense que c'est un rapport
à pouvoir faire ses valises et rentrer
chez lui
non c'est vrai que c'est ok après tu
vois enfin je t'assure et moi j'ai su le
blog le match de hand vers
maxime contre 1 contre la faim coca cola
est ok donc maxime était a été à deux je
crois avant la bulle est et on sait bien
que maxime en bullet et des justes
infernale et carbenas et passe à 40 du
tout et au final car ana a mis 6 3
maximum et gagner noyade en regardant
un match en plus de variance quoi ouais
ça m'aiderait à me le dire
ça veut rien dire donc on va on va pas
essayer de les coincer pour l'instant je
viens d'un jeu 5 pour venir défendre un
f5 poussé dans l'herbe 4
mai à voir ce qu'on a mais s'inquiète
pas fou 17 qui peut poser problème et
c'est ça des cycliques ou sur les cases
blanches ouais
et wealthy par le jura bernois en
fougueuse noir donc du coup les
blanchons cases blanches auraient pillay
avait un problème pour mon pied je sais
pas comment le défendent donc en fait ça
paraît c'est hyper bien pour les noirs
et ben c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour
nîmes c'est rennes qui est en ligne au
total donc là
en plus il a la voix faible donc avec
quelques secondes à a pendu le stéphane
ça va être l'enfer je pense
lever cette position pour être le roi
noir voilà c'est clair en plus les
décisions de la pendue à l'horreur du
coup je pense qu'on aura droit à une
dernière partie après celle là ce qui
reste huit minutes sur le compteur et
[Musique]
je pense pas que mon geste inutile cette
partie là ils sont 36 aux
investissements mais chacun
et foucault f5 car elles prendraient
voir est-ce qu'on peut jouer si je fous
j'ai six pour essayer de matières
grasses est sur deux choses à
moitié la mouette dame jk peut-être là
avec dame g6 on va commencer à créer les
cases blanches pour la science
même fou g6 intéressant avec dams est
vite allé à coup des meneurs des cartes
blanches et la mort pendant une garde et
les dames quand même la finale avec time
france c'est ça qu'il faut prendre il
faut ainsi se connaissant
sa pensée
on apprend de plus la part de coups
droits côté ouvert à deux secondes qu'on
dit secondera il vient d'échanger les
dames fait mentir
alors
bon ben maintenant on peut dire que ça
va sûrement faire ou à ses yeux le
sailhet voyait fixer en cause et artix
et bien ces rapports qu'il ya bien
craquer dans cette partie arrive a dit
vas manger à l'astral un geste est ici
ouais alors en rien franchement il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de de résistance dans
les rangs des parties avait deux joueurs
ne lâchent rien et elles ont du mal à
convertir violence et c'est parti comme
quoi faut se battre à chaque partie un
gars vraiment 5 plus une en prêtant il
faut se battre jusqu'au bout donc cela
c'est la dernière je pense
vraiment super codir celle échange de
dames qui a
bon il a dû peut échanger pour une
certaine raison avant mais j'ai pas un
rang élevé convertir avec les daims la
position il n'a pas réussi et c'est là
c'est un peu le drame web ont été remis
à ses rimes là ça fait deux parties
oui frôlé la correctionnelle il s'en
sort à chaque fois mais c'est pas le
fruit du hasard quand tu dis ses fans
n'ont pas mal de réussite car c'est avec
pour pour s'arrimer bon c'est un gros
bosseur il se bat jusqu'au bout il ya
des ressources c'est bien tu vois c'est
une grosse qualité trouver des
ressources en partie le
passé laissé
ok il est moins bien dans beaucoup de
parties mais bon
quand même
ces rapports quoiqu'il ait pas mal avec
pippa personne doit et mais n'arrivent
toujours à
regarder pour trouver
ouais mais c'est un super exemple pour
tout le monde
nous les premiers moments j'estime que
justement c'est quelque chose qu'on fait
assez bien avec l'expérience et le sait
le fait de s'accrocher dans les
positions difficiles on appris en soirée
on peut et on voit que les mêmes les
joueurs de très haut niveau ne maîtrise
pas tout quand ils sont en difficulté
s'accroît donc ça c'est vraiment super
exemple c'est clair
c'est que la
cave à l'étranger 3h projet 3 dans la
croix sordo début de londres après sa
dérive est
hélas je verrais bien un petit le cilss
des 5 parce que c'est toujours pas ça
c'est parce que tu vas jouer parce
qu'ils aiment b3 peut arriver
la panne est ouverte
c'est
en tout cas un grand bond il ya trois
pièces mineurs sur blanc et du coup nous
va jouer quoi pousser ses 5 à ce que
disait après ton des cinq à ses fans
pour tout ouvrir sur noir normalement
pour le fou g7 très important donc on va
essayer de jouer toujours sur la couleur
de inverse du fou la versa donc l'info
quasiment jusqu'au qu'évidemment contre
115 noir tombe à 1 foot 15 mois
là le problème du dernier où donc des 5
c'est très bien si les noirs il va faire
ses cinq dans la foulée mais faut être
sûr c'est papa censure mais mais du coup
là surtout des trois jeux peu calmé jeu
c'est simple parce que son clan croire
qu'un tampon est de
celles là donc c'est ça est possible
d'en scène à
ce sujet par promet deux malheureusement
ces 5 n'était pas très bon niveau il est
tombé de la pression sur ce qui est
intéressant mais gestion parce que tu
vois quand même que le renard est assez
ouvert le pion ça me fait peur quand
même mais j'ai un passé qui fait peur le
curé ces sociétés est faible
c'est ainsi encore indécis en tout cas
on voit que les deux joueurs se suivent
au niveau du temps le premier qui ont
arraché au niveau du temps souffrant
depuis le départ
c'est comme
la notion la plus importante les parties
sont relativement équilibrés et il faut
garder du temps
regardez
ont un regard des camélias de fordham
éclate
c'est intéressant
de vous
c'est court c'est
comme marcher quatre places qui peut
arriver un cap à mais j'aime bien
prendre les 15 hockey oui parce qu'il
est en fait c'est ok on voudrait en
baisse kamal est là pour pouvoir manger
des deux serait possible
voilà bien des blancs c'est notre
tendance
bon c'est la danse donc lors de leurs
dix au brésil ait pas d'accord avec moi
mais un mets en pratique j'aime bien les
blancs parce que bike m déception qui
est fait puisque qui est passé je suis
d'accord avec toi sale et c'est la
position blanche plus naturel avec
l'idée de jouer pour le kg au passé
c'est que pour le pion à 6o city en
l'air ils sont il ya peut-être damas
trois à damas trois quarts aile et des 4
et 6 et c'est simple comme ça alors
quand même pas mal et essayer de
débloquer pioncer maintenant
car elle n'a pas aujourd'hui lancé à
votre repos
il jouera demain demain 13h30 sur la sur
la même chaîne sur thiès com fr
on comprend bien se régaler est ce qu'on
va voir une victoire enfin d'un super du
monde ça s'est fait en
maintenant avec impatience demain donc
c'est quoi demain sait qu'arsène blanc
oui
écoutons pas
bon en fait pour le spectacle c'est
clair que que
c'est clair que qu'on a envie qu'il y
avait des parties si
perso pour le spectacle j'aimerais bien
que
ce n'est pas en gagnant pour la première
ça forcerait en une grosse réaction de
40 cm et je pense que ça pourrait
paraître 400 m malgré tout les favoris
dans ce match et c'est vrai que bon moi
je suis
là comme dans les films ou quoi c'est ça
que tu veux ouais
genre le méchant qui gagnent jusqu'à la
fin il va quand même faire c'est
le délit d'aidé sera pour que le match
soit plus intéressant j'ai envie de dire
avant une vraie réaction
d'ankara le sait mais
voilà
donc du coup la cavale de quatre
intéressés
la malle poste
5 en fait c'est pas l'aide de pièces qui
va avoir à il ya peut-être damas trois
qui attaquent la tour euh ouais mais ça
peut leur suffire
damas trois tourtes en d2
comment on fait alors ses 4es damas 3g
quand même plein de pièces en prison
même si je joue avec ma tour n'importe
où par exemple il fait quoi georges
tomber tu vois
ouais j'ai tout en l'air ou du moins
beaucoup de monde
exerce il a
donc six matches
pour cette partie du coup je sais pas
s'il y aura une pause ou pas ce que
c'est toutes les heures normalement mais
du coup je pense qu'ils auraient dû
pause cam entre les deux sens entre les
deux factions heureuse je demande le
résultat de quinssaines dépôt mais c'est
la journée de repos ouais ça n'a pas
jojo c'est le scar ce chef
le speech s avec deux joueurs qui ont le
potentiel pour
prochainement faire trois des candidats
et après aller au pascal dumont c'est
encore autre chose mais
peut estimer que c'est les joueurs du
speech s ils ont tous une place au tour
des candidats maintenant les places sont
chères déjà aux trois des candidats je
croix du mont jobin voit pas tous les
jours du dessus du scud c est quand même
des
meilleurs duos en vain
donc en fait c'est quasiment tous là
sauf bien sûr car ce n est pas
moi ils vont occuper je crois
comme vous le dis il pourrait se cacher
la forêt de repos sera bien pouvoir
franchement car cet avis comme je le
faisais ce que je comprends pas bien
mais sachez avant ses fans pas mal de
trois brit dans notre vie et c'est
franchement au bout d'un moment là les
mecs selon lui mérite parce que leur
niveau de qualité ne baisse pas trop ok
ils font des bêtises normal c'est sa
voix de super joueurs c'est hyper rapide
mais on voit qu'ils sont toujours
présents parce qu'ils enchaînent ils
enchaînent il enchaîne c'est c'est
monstrueux quoi
donc oui havel a perdu contre a perdu
contre caravane à 7 et quand c'était
c'était il ya deux jours
c'était deux jours je crois
ils perdent 1 point
par un point
ils menaient de deux points avant le
bullet et au final hyper
hyper d'un point il perd dans la partie
quand peu triste
c'est hyper aléatoire de toute façon ça
je veux pas grand chose qu'on voit si
rien ne se passait bon alors c'est ce
que parce que richard laporte va gagner
cette finale qui est
sympa mais difficile à gagner
techniquement
la section a toujours toujours
prompt à 5 salaires vraiment beaucoup
mieux mais là il y aura ces spécimens et
une minute chacun maintenant enfin je
pense que si on enlève les deux pions à
je pense que c'est quand même
c'est quand même plus simple pour les
noirs et belle chance de bien quand même
pour les noirs mais ici avec tour des
sites qui peuvent arriver le pion à ses
skis qui est faible et puis insister
c'est pas facile à je pense qu'en
pratique
de blancs d'oeufs dans le sens de de ne
pas perdre mais peut-être même de gagner
un sommet dimanche à toi si ça peut ça
peut vite tourner un jeu pensant
notamment vers les sept qui peut être
fait des fois aussi quand il faut ces
quatre des six enfin petit peu attention
également sa position s'est passé c'est
un point
dans ton des six a l'air d'être le
crooner moine mais ya quand même fou
beslan l'observa
ce que le full g7 domine quand même
super bien cavaliers f3
j'ai suivi ta master class de tout à
l'heure sur la domination du du fou
qu'on le cavalier
ah bah ça je m'y attendais pas trop
bon ben ok manuk tout de suite
plu tout de suite c'est bizarre mais il
n'a pas voulu continuer avec baignoire
ouais peut-être les coeurs de ceux de ce
fou de se faisaient ce plusieurs partis
et aux
fêtes richert rapporte pour l'instant
c'est horrible pour lui je trouve qu'il
domine bien bas depuis trois parties là
ça va être trois grâce à un énormissime
avantages et deux avantages de foutu en
l'air quoi donc c'est comme un petit peu
embêtant histoire
du coup là on va passer sur une sur une
pause je vais juste me cheikh
ahmed c'est vrai que j'ai plus le goût
parce que lors des mois qui sait qui
c'est qu'est-ce qui a planté de talent
mais je crois que les joueurs sont
partis en pause je vais dans le zoom
on aurait pu juste revenir ça dérange
pas stephane sur le moment il perd hyper
la pièce richard rapporte sita moyen de
l'avant ou non
petites secondes alors c'est le moment
qu'on a eu
est-ce que je vous rappelle qu'il avait
une position de tir désespéré
nihal sarine contre richard à partir
des buts ou plus ouais on peut la
retrouver je vais de la retrouver je
vais aller prier à profil de rapport il
veut les voir c'est parti je pense c'est
une partie sud qui là qu'il a fait mieux
du point oui oui c'est ça
ne trompe pas du coup voilà
celle là on en était là à peu près
voilà tu vas voir c'est juste avant
voilà donc là on annonçait une vie qu'on
annonçait une victoire noire on
annonçait que you buy c'était bien il se
battait avec
avec les avec les blancs il a raison
forcément et en fait il ya une rame
aidera camille qu'avenir de 5000 à 36 a
même pu l'emporter plus tôt à ercis
voilà ce qu'il se passe rien et là
regardez ça c'est marrant parce que les
noirs ils ont attaqué fou donc les
blancs l'ont défendu d'une manière
machinale et en même temps ils ont tenu
une petite un titre x sur le cavalier e
5 et piémont sa menace f3 c'est ça qui
est rigolo en fait c'est vous c'est
parce qu'il s'est dit il joue ça parce
que ça dépend le fou mais en fait ils
vous savez ça défend fouet en même temps
et au yen mais la tactique voilà c'est
mignon petit moment
et à la place de jeu propre et six mois
je vais bientôt 26 ans
ouais on avait dit pour taper le pion f
le fermage et c'est bien mais il faut
poser assez vite ce plan parce qu'en
fait après f3 binger qui a valu le 3 est
maintenant c'est vrai que ba leurs
ouailles un tir de mettre aussi un camp
je peux tomber six tombes et un jeu au
réseau terrain jean sirois y aura
toujours tour est un math et sur quoi je
veux binger du tour f1 tous rêvent de g
j'ai plein de bonnes choses sérieuses en
pratique en plus il ya un milieu aussi
l'option eux deux qui va tomber
ça m'a l'air quand même assez simple
ouais ouais ben là c'est juste entre
guillemets
fameux pas de bol
là c'est assez incroyable on est mal
tombé
bon du coup voir on va repartir là
dessus je pense qu'on est qu'ils posent
encore trois minutes un le gas
gas et mon truc
et des joueurs sont en pause 1
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu on résoud pas
plus que ses pertes à sion il faut des
[ __ ] les gars vous savez ce sont des
stream important il faut des pubs donc
les cas on va revenir dans trois quatre
minutes l'histoire que ça recommence et
que vous puissiez voir avec les pubs des
pièces comme un qui sont très
importantes pour vous le savez tous
elle a tout à l'heure et le jeu a tout
de suite
[Musique]
les gars on est revenu parmi vous le
match reprend donc l eau
donc du coup alors pourquoi et bien non
en fait
je vois pas les scores sur sûr
on atteint 4,5 3,5 non il ya quatre et
demi à trois ans et demi pour sa rivale
à
celle de presque là ça va être bon c'est
la plus fidèle à vous rappeler
maintenant on est en 3 + 1 fini de rire
déjà 5 + 1 c'était speed quand même
donc un nouveau un début du fourgon il a
mis son cas manière en c3 deuxième coup
richard importe mais il avait refusé car
derrière avec détroit donc on est
retombé dans un début du fou il n'a pas
voulu redouter une délicieuse petrov
voilà ils préfèrent les personnes musée
avant les pièces sur l'échiquier et pas
se faire bloquer la tentative de faire
un disque donc mettre le score de joie
qui devait venir ici
et ça joue assez assez logique pour
l'instant
être prochainement un petit rock qui
roulent en alliés décident d'échanger
dame cher rapporte ok
pourquoi pas et maintenant les deux
joueurs veulent bien changé d'âme mais à
leur condition
en l'occurrence il ya sarine il veut que
ça quand même à s'ouvre on valorise et
ses pièces cette tour en l'occurrence
voilà c'est chose faite et allez mon
petit prono pour cette partie un match
nul c'est pas je pronostique déjà un
match pas sûr du tout parce qu'autant en
partie lente il y aurait une bonne
chance que ça arrive ce match nul là en
partie avec 2000 chacun
peut se passer encore beaucoup de choses
encore
je suis assez d'accord avec toi
bon et puis là-bas c'est l'instance et
on est dans la zone un peu plate de la
partie et un moment dès que le temps va
descendre au dessous de la minute last
show c'est pour ça que vous voyez que
les deux joueurs font attention de jouer
quand même relativement vite voilà trois
personnes ça peut vite tourner un autant
c'est une bien dans ce matin à la limite
je préfère sonne jouer en 3 0 je crois
toujours en 3 061
et du et du coup un franchement 3 + 1 on
dit qu'on a un petit rajoutant mais le
plus un c'est juste il nous permet de
gagner une position
complètement gagnante pas plus que ça
enfin plus un mais pas grand chose on
l'a vu tout à l'heure ses nas a commencé
en apportent eux pointent des qui
j'avais dix secondes chacun alors que
sont ils font partie ces deux joueurs
des meilleurs joueurs de la planète quoi
donc éviter la zone d'ultra zai note
voilà la leçon du jour qui nous est
donné dans cette large puisque même tu
vois enfin il ya l'état de cues défi
puisque je souvent sur czech comme tous
les mardis
cette transmission et j'avais besoin
faute en quoi parce que ben en fait tu
penses que ça va mais sacrément d'une
seconde c6 mais vraiment rien donc en
fait voilà en plus ça il fallait faire
une heure et demie de cinq bus une
démo relativement lent et donc de
patience en 2003 une séquelle un
changement donc voir comment s'adapter à
ça
et c'est certain que au fur et à mesure
même sombré george clooney y aura quand
même de la fatigue et de plus en plus de
gars qu'on a vu déjà des gamins
finalement dans la première partie
forcément il y en a dans tous les matchs
à dabou catherine r
il a je pense de plus la tendance
s'accélère plus on aura bien une vie
normale aux minimes 1
très bien joué c'est marrant on voit
qu'elle joue à une vitesse colossal et
malgré tout on voit qui joue extrêmement
vite le temps s'effrite peu à peu et là
on va rentrer dans une zone qui commence
à être dangereuse après ça sentait
depuis le départ cette partie on la voit
bien
se finir en match nul parce qu'elle est
très bloqués le fou qui est restant dans
cette position fixe et cases blanches
donc c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
mais les cavaliers blanc sont aussi très
mots n'ont pas de grosse inquiétude
j'aimais bien 4 h 5 avec les morts avant
le récit de provoquer g5 à cavaler
derrière 5 c'est intéressant
on n'a pas été joué la fosse est un jeu
pensé obligatoires ouais c'est un peu
ton idée quand même souvent puisque ils
essayent de provoquer des petits coups
de pions pour faire des trous est rentré
dans la position noir donc alors juste
pour expliquer g5 ce registre très mal
joué un peu cavalier ce qui n est acquis
quand m6
donc les noirs n'ont absolument pas
besoin de faire g5
google en fait valve essayer de
provoquer g5 de noir car c'est l'hiver
un quart des trophées provoqué
ces faits mais en même temps donc c'est
un seul trou dans tout la position
lorgnant sarine scène jamie en mode
tortue le mode tortue vous connaissez
sans doute ces voix là on créa la terre
à passe et on se bat et on attend marois
17 terme à des semaines de 6 km et f4
peut être
le plan des marins pour l'idée d'une
part à froid je pense que cadel evans et
7 je vois pas le cas mais dans des six
et 24 derrière on croit 17 ce qui va
tuer le port de douvres bon je pense
qu'il est de gagner rien que pour ça et
mes amis mais de gagner deux points
rapport mais je veux dire va durer
quatre heures ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle car c'est une bonne nouvelle
mais je reste sur mon prono du départ du
cndd
forteresse mutuel après il va quand même
essayer maintenant avec les noirs parce
qu'il a quand même une bonne nouvelle
avec l'arrivée de pau cavaliers
ces cinq prises prises
et voir ce qui se passait ce qui peut
activer le roi est ce que vous pouvez
faire c'est bien je donnais qu'elle va
faire friis prises et ses 4 twh à donner
à ces quatre lots
la pollution elle est hyper hyper ferme
est
une cavalière de chat ou
g14 tiens je crois
je vois pas un monde où le noir quelque
chose vraie forteresse mutuelle ouais ça
à part nul l'affairé noir mutuellement
mais bon
avec 15 secondes ou pas s'endormir
single
d'activer par deux cavaliers des cinq
ans
ça m'inquiète attention de temps ils ont
la saveur du lait mais juste répéter
il va tenter il va tenter avec des
blancs et leur retard by tente parce que
ça arrive
la gamme black cats second c'est hyper
dangereux avec la plus a
donc c'est pour ça qu'il attendant je
pense sincèrement pas vraiment vraiment
de problème je pense dans la position
où le problème de cette cadence une
ambitieuse c'est un échec survient
cinq amis et soutiens des stocks pour
essayer d'embrouillés l'adversaire et là
tout peut se passer ouais c'est
maintenant du coup il ya un fond de sac
protéger sa ses protégés pour les
plantes donc loi j'avais vraiment trop
partir loin les échanges de 1,3 g tient
dans une position où on fait attention
ménagers
bon ça reste serré retenu probablement
mais je comprends aussi longtemps ils
sont à 2 2 vous aimez intéressant
il faut jouer en mode réflexe ça peut
traquer ça répète et je m'en sers ouais
ce serait logique mais n'arrête pas il
tente son va-tout pour ses shows cette
attention pions il ya pourtant qu'il va
arriver
aussi un jour les 1er 3e et il a
finalement quasiment tous donné la règle
et blanc une seconde chacun agnès et
hyper chaud il s'est fait enfermer sont
fous aie aie aie ça retourner à nouveau
site est ce sa vitesse d'autant plus
qu'à un moment les noirs sont devenus
gagnant puisqu'il s'est fait enfermer
son fonds à deux c'était marrant cette
petite séquence
d'après li évaluer la position qui a
changé
chacun s'était pas sûr de dire est ce
que moi je moi je sens où on n'a plus
vraiment depuis un froid à penser c'est
difficile à dire mais en tout cas c'est
un beau spectacle
ces deux joueurs ouais c'est super ça
m'a vraiment pas bon de toute façon soit
une de plus en plus sympa dans moins de
le raccourcissement des cadences en vrai
c'est clair
généralement c'est là on prend du
plaisir à regarder c'est quand ça va
vite et qu'on espère seulement les
choses sa femme en lui
une sorte de débugage obama ici qui a
été joué ceux qui connaissent qu'à et c3
il faut être quatre très rapidement - ue
kf3 deuxième mais
on est dedans dans une opposition mona
nihal sarine il va travailler cette
position il vient d'éclater la structure
de pions et ici ça va être des cavaliers
à la carte et compagnie cavalia qu'un à
tour 6 1 6 4 des choses comme ça avec
b300 nottie et les noirs vont réagir sur
notre part e101 kapsys le sac alors dame
à 5 alors le score je vais le voir à
côté l'épisode en bas la suède est ce
que tu vas
quatre rapports 5 niasse arrive
donc on encore qu'un de trois piscines
et ensuite on va
on aura une demi-heure de une plus une
qui est du lez
ils sont en surchauffe et pour le bullet
comment ils sont en train de se chauffer
pour bullet et là on vient d'avoir un
quelque chose d'assez incroyable avec ce
tour priceline de richard rapporte à
tempo
cette aide non à la porte il avait un
très content désolé je crois vous
montrer la caméra bien
moi je pensais qu'il était une faute de
souris ils veulent qu'ils voulaient rsa
fou prend 1,5 et bateaux reprend comme
il l'a fait mais apparemment vous être
sale involontaire
donc ouais tout en confiance tout en
contrôle et après l'annonce mat bon sauf
qu'à un moment à tout le monde et blanc
pour jouer f4 et ça m'étonnerait que si
le fou ce musée si le foot 15 mois ce
mur mais pas ouvrir tête avec le cadre
là il ya plusieurs options qui
permettent dans land gérer cela honda
mousser car c'est assez malin et plein
de petit
gibier intrus m et c'est un peu la
structure attaqué le tuant ses droits
par le cas partout 7 mois vraiment ils
ont des idées en tout cas parce que
dommage car dame c4
on est enfin s'il arrive à quelqu'un ya
le sparring 4 il veut valoriser ces
tours
est joli coup à jouer
il veut rentrer en 21.33 mon voeu
4,6 des rallyes des aides mais aussi
aussi jouable ou en tout cas si les
bleus arrivent en gestion de 4 je pense
que ça va se rétribue
bien bien bien préparés toute cette
séquence
mais c'est compliqué quand même hein
c'est de l'industrie pour la douche père
à 3,24 ça fait quand même beaucoup
croient vraiment vraiment utile
maintenant sur les joues un coût soit il
est adorable touré afin d'apprendre à
3,57 pas si clair je commence à angers
jean ferrat
c'est clair l'allemand je vous fais
attention si je te mange à 3 mais qui a
déjà deux secousses mon courage prend 1
avec nous français 300
noms il a quand même réussi un joli tour
de force avec le fait de les bouffer une
minute agnel sarine
yes alors j'ai beaucoup à l'ordinateur
grc apparaissent extraterrestre mais les
a déjoué par warfarine
aux extraterrestres
et en fait il est vrai que maintenant la
position s'est rééquilibré au niveau
matos mais on préfère dix mille fois les
les blancs particulièrement une
consolidation à terme d'un médecin
cavale de quatre pour faire mal sur des
cases noires
le roi noir paraît fragile et en plus on
peut continuer à jouer aux échecs dans
cette position aussi en gobant le matos
il ya le pion c6 qui en l'air les
cavaliers de 36
17 et le pire c'est que même jean retour
des luttes j'aurais quand même qu'à
valider cette place qui entourent frange
retour 8 me du couloir à tous les
problèmes là vous voyez tous les
problèmes de
sur quatre mois et donnant ses gardes du
corps changer les pièces
mais d'un point et tower à evry ciment
frais dans le set
bon je pense que sur foot dessin qui va
vouloir jouer quand même source est
généralement 14 ans s'était blessé même
des choses pendant les écoles
et oui c'est parti mon volant on est
passé sur un petit massage positionnelle
d'un cavalli qui veut venir à yves si ça
pourrait très sympa aussi car plus on
fait 5 ans que durera
le g5 je pense qu'on vient
ici c'est bien aussi c'était pas
non plus s'il ya vraiment plusieurs fois
dans ses positions la domination mais
jusqu'au on a toujours eu du mal à
convertir davantage particulièrement
pour richard rapporté là j'ai
l'impression que
je vois bien
je vais bien la sarine convertir cette
fois parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
problèmes il n'ya pas simple de jouer
l'imposition ne vous voulez cinq voyages
de bien sûr
position
vous et
là j'entends
que vous essayez ça qui peut faire
attention et un petit raisonnement qui
voulait créer mais bon la gastro
strasbourg châtain
simplifie lanthier l'anti jeu peut être
mais la maison la raison c'est le
meilleur moyen de glace carnac et
donc ton raynaud qui avait demandé cinq
immenses ouais et les rangées de sur
l'a62 au toit je
pense que je peux toujours
moins trois mois j'ai quatre tunisiens
l'entretien sont atteintes mais tout est
faible je l'avais fait la ccfl à 5 9 a
bien travaillé
donc là il va gagner on va side qui va
commencer à s'envoler avec un petit plus
de deux ans je pense oui
ouais si bon moralement il doit toucher
richard rapporte parce que dans match on
veut pas dire qu'ils fassent un mauvais
match en terme de qualité de jeu
franchement c il joue très bien c'est
juste qu'il a craqué dans certaines
positions
mois de niassa rinne a été plus constant
particulièrement dans les camps le temps
est très limitée
en synchro génériques ne pas te mentir
pour les ssii sont aussi c'est vraiment
voilà
c'est bientôt la fin ça c'est ça sa
bande ont tendance à
abandonner en plus maintenant oui le
second pieds deux pouces de haut pour
saina du mont cenis rarement à un béret
à manger les plus au manque la vente
mois plus de temps pour l'asie ligne
d'arrières centraux faire assez
insensible du
psv les partis l'udc et une lamentation
instant no 5 attention le tour n'est pas
prenable mais là mesdames les cafés
chics et menacé
si kiev
dire oui et bon bah on est sûr ça
ressemble un petit peu a trop moche ce
qui sauf que s'est jouée sur des cap des
5 fu g5 au début et du coup on n'a pas
les fous pour thème fou prend 9 6 donc
on se prend toujours à chis donc sebaoun
ouverture marginal encore qui a été joué
par richard rapporte fini joue tout le
temps des trucs comme ça un petit peu
alambiqué l'impression jeu il est comme
ça là pour eux directement exactement
c'est pas comme si j'avais joué ce avant
ce match
le marché s'est complètement les
musiciens alors c'est vrai il y arrivait
enfin je me rendais en fait est en tout
cas une
partie du bois
son style un petit peu
et ça s'est bien calmé quand même la
position là d'un coup
par rapport à ce qui était annoncé
donc quand tu le coup c'est ça mais ça
va venir à rennes qu'il a joué à quatre
c'est intéressant pour jouer contre
madame b 6
provoqué à 1,5 éventuelles et gagner la
case bessin
bien joué voilà soir à cinq voies
d'accès
à la casse un
bon petit tout petit plus blanc dans
cette position parce qu'on a plus d
espace à l dames c'est un plus agréable
mais c'est pas grand somme en
jeu vitesse le deux joueurs que ses
propres n'y a pas de
ne pas déclarer maintenant on voit cette
euphorie autour de la case de sacs
scellés ces bâtisses à l'horizon pour le
boss entretenant la leucémie aiguë et
c'est le match des 8e de finale qui a
été jouée pouvoir semaine dernière
malheureusement
je vais mettre des caméras ici des
joueurs mais là j'ai un gel douche un
gros bug avec des zooms qui ne marche
pas donc où je vous ai mis ça pour ça
aujourd'hui
voilà on essaie de faire qu'on peut mais
ça c'est dommage delà de la semaine
d'avant donc le score et vous pouvez le
voir en bas en bas à gauche agnes szavay
6 6 4 voilà
certes pas si main pour les blancs qui
ont un petit plus à faire fructifier
pas grand chose mais il ya un pied isolé
sur la couleur de leur propre foule qui
isolait fx r
[Musique]
ça semble un peu plus facile à jouer un
côté blanc encore que
rien n'est clair surtout venir sign et
tout le temps bien longtemps il joue
vraiment très très rapidement
été rejoint par l'oea nous a dit que ça
serait dur pour richard rapporte richard
a repensé je le vois bien il doit il
doit avoir envie de sacrifier amants et
fils en avant si elle avait vu sa
variation c3 pour l'inspiration
reveillère qu'est ce que je pense des
castes c'est pas fameux des quatre
bananes à risque
c'est un peu compliqué mais en fait le
rythme est elle qui doit il doit prendre
des décisions et du coup je suis sûr
qu'ils les regardent déploie dans la
demi seconde mais il faut qu'ils
avancent quoi parce que là toute la
solution était très agréable maintenant
la cible en d5 est moins importante que
la cible en c3
et attention nous lançons un type
attention il ya le match douleur car il
va découvrir et oui tous retrouvés
oubliées ou amélie mais une pression de
dingue a en fait il est en train de
complètement sombré est là richard
rapporte malheureusement pour lui il
avait très très bien joué tout à l'heure
et tu l'avais annoncé avant son départ
et c'est en train de se produire pour la
mort
on sent que ça va pas cette histoire
mais il est le quatrième à égalité à
quatre breaks ghana
bon maintenant il ya toujours le fait de
de gagner cette position gagnante
seulement à chaque fois est rien ça
c'est vraiment hyper classe je n'ai pas
fait attention c'est pas cavalier preuve
de naïveté en revenir
mignon et on mange la tour b derrière
c'est un échange au final
un moment et voilà c'est plus trois pour
pour ça rime donc il faut vraiment une
belle et saine de suite royale là il
faut une réaction de la part du joueur
en noir est ce que pareil c'est comme ça
non on connaît ça ses fans sans doute
arrivé en tout cas moi je sais que ça
m'arrive sur l'intérêt de mme carty
d'elysée par un joueur je prends une
défaite ça va je joue toujours
correctement deux défaites qui bout d'un
moment ça commence à bien déconner tu as
bien difficile et est ce qui est bien
c'est qu'au bout d'un moment on peut
arrêter là ne peut pas et ne peut pas il
ne peut pas doxa il faut il faut il faut
en fait de pas les moyens de se former
en fait là quand tu palente aux malades
c'est quand tu fais bon là on peut se
placer cette carte quand même pour
pour le thunder
ça peut être long quoi ça peut être long
quand j'en ai gravi le plus haut sommet
des fêtes et savait que l'ampli n'ont
pas le choix il peut paraski tu ne peux
pas rentrer chez lui on peut arrêter
qu'il faut continuer et j'avoue que
c'est pas facile mais psychologiquement
quand tu veux un match comme ça et que
tu peux pas arrêter là c'est difficile
donc
donc là ça c'est que l'équipe r je crois
rapport je pense que là il faut il faut
arrêter l'hémorragie il faut essayer au
moins de taper tout appris mais ce qui
est marrant ça qu'il arrête l'hémorragie
en essayant non pas de faire nul ses
fans il essaie de ne pas lancer une
énorme une énorme attaque sur sur mia
sarine il a choisi le début hollandais
la hollandaise
réputé très agressif alors il ya un
président fantastique après rapport
c'est un joueur je pense qu'ils bon et
hyper agressive je pense que c'est un
jour inutiles
t1 en maths oui il peut pas tout il veut
pas trop jouer autrement et il est tout
le temps comme ça agressif c'est pas un
joueur c'est pour ça qu'ils c'est un des
joueurs qu'on apprécie au niveau parce
qu'il est quand même très différent des
autres qui sont plus conservateurs on va
dire avec sita les blancs tu dois je
propre petit plus si tu as les noirs
puent à tenir lui on a l'impression
vraiment qu'il veut tout le temps gagner
avec des deux couleurs en jouant des
ouvertures fantasque donc ça un des nos
parcs et c'est franchement sympa on voir
maria est assez il ya ce niveau là c'est
difficile quand même de maintenir ce
niveau est aussi bas tu vois de pouvoir
jouer des ouvertures comme tu dis un
fantasque à ce niveau là c'est difficile
quoi parce que mon venin
la préparation des joueurs en face c'est
quand même
quelque chose donc la baisse reste
morose et vite chez les porcs qui y fait
ressembler un peu dans la veine issus de
jeux tous les gants dit jouer là comment
s'appelait là il veut que des trucs que
le truc bizarre à servier savait le jour
le contrôlant bien le bail jouant notre
grand bien de
la figurine
tout soit on note élevée selon elle se
faisait plaisir à tous les ouvertures
qui ont mauvaise réputation
comme quoi c'est ce qu'on vous a dit on
peut tout jouer aux échecs après faut
avoir beaucoup bossé et c'est pour ça
qu'elle plus les amateurs d'entre vous
vous conseille plutôt les ouvertures
avec les les bons principes et là
celle-là c'est déjà parti pas mal mais
là on se retrouve également composé donc
ça va être normalement la course attaque
ou l'exécution prise je ne compte pas ce
qui c'est à toutes les pièces surprise
il ya ça ça sent prise et j'ai aussi la
cave et qui peut prendre
tout est en prime avoir d'allégeance
rouge laisse alors c'est le coup
l'indien
c'est le coût de leur dit alors bon
l'idée j'imagine bien sûr que vous prend
tout reprend je me lasse d'un projet 2
est jeune aussi la dame ya trop keita
emprise cavaliers à ses trois buts ça ne
passe pas grand chose babu un croyant
réaction de richard important si ça
m'arrivait cru
et des gagnants maintenant 1
maintenant j'espère que c'est plus
facile sur elle prend 1,3 que je
commence en fait manger 4
way ranger 4 1 là je vais rester avec
beaucoup de choses en pressant l'air et
tu peux pas
manger là parce que je mange la dame
c'est comme on connaissait le doublé
chaque langue à rien de voir la double
attaque de da da c'est lui ce monstrueux
ce parti c'est monstrueux la dame j'ai
surtout après avoir pris de but depuis
l'avant et pratiques du
reste de la partie c'est que la
voix sayah cavani vrai problème c'est
parce qu'il a oublié ni a sign on sait
pas s'il avait vu tout ça ce qu'ils
voient tellement de trucs aussi de
dépenser plus qu'ils voient ce qu'ils ne
voient pas c'est que là mais la
voilà il ya une tour cercle en moi elle
deux cavaliers vont se retrouver en
prise après avoir invité
surprise que je trouve bien c'est ça
alors ça a quel essai 6 des français 6 à
gourbeyre il veut briser la france pense
peuvent
d'un vous la reprise d'un prend
et
en tout de suite ou en tout cas ça fait
réfléchir
ouais
que c'est sûr que
[Musique]
bien sûr la tentative de niall sarens
est prête à trouver une paire peut être
quelque chose comme ça en tout cas de
encore vous êtes foutus voilà c'est ce
qu'on fait tous vous essayé d'attaquer
le roi et vous verrez bien mais alors
qu'elle ait des
enquêtes pour b1 mais perd la tour j'ai
encore une tour de plus craindre un truc
que ça
ainsi claire maintenant c'est beaucoup
moins claire
un parti est incroyable elle l'est
toujours en fait parce qu'on pensait que
ça va être très encore des ressources
pratiques importance parce que
lecavalier ne pas sortir en fait dans ce
cas une cadre in may a tourné qui peut
arriver là c'est pas évident qu'un porte
bien
avec
des cinq qui peut arriver si tu bouges
adam
west on a peur de son cours comme tour
au delà pour défendre cavaliers parce
que la dame dessin voilà richard a pensé
y
aulas là ça s'excite et le roi de
richard rapporte il est quand même en
difficulté aux parieurs de f4 paraît
logique mais qui est il assez ça sans
drame comme un harnais enfin il ya des
dames des cinq échecs partout si on veut
à présent c'est qu'ils sont promptes à
vallier versailles on en perd en faire
une pièce en fait c'est horrible pour
lui enfin tenu le choc puisqu'on peut
rien faire non mais c'est même des deux
et maintenant voilà tour des deux mains
tour d2 peyo a
dont on voit le
jour à varazdin finale pression de
résultat première sarine
ne perd va pas
donc il convertit ça se passe facile
c'est fini ça y est que plus rattraper
la teinture à leurs plus hauts parleurs
thirion type total live vient de
s'apercevoir tour français 3 c'est bon
après c'est trop trop facile d'ailleurs
répartis et exceptionnel que ces faits
aient vraiment et il a la poisse
jusqu'au bout parce qu'on pensait qu'il
avait gagné dommage qu'on puisse pas
revoir le moment le moment en fait parce
que c'était vraiment magnifique un
financement du haut niveau il n'ya
sarine baïla la réussite du mac qui joue
que huit fois c'est toujours pareil
mais ouais
non c'est moi parce que je sais c'est un
rythme baisse voire
plus de calais la danse pour 8,4 alors
forcément être difficile de se remettre
pour
richard rapporte là il vient de prendre
un coup sûr enfin oui il allait il a
potentiellement revenir dans le match et
du coup maintenant là il paraît en voir
difficulté
c'est sa dernière chance qui vient de
disparaître
mais bon je sais pas j'ai l'aï femme et
je vous dis père bien riche et
rapportent pas qu'à nous laisser juste
dans l'ultra zélotes qui sont au pouvoir
il fait un super match ils posent
beaucoup de problèmes à sarine mais il
craque beaucoup en fin de partie en
date- note tient pas la pression dans ce
match
ce qu'on peut retenir soucier
l'epsic logiquement ça doit être
l'horreur mais bon parties suivantes
hier par direct et c'est assez propre ce
qui le fait
non mais un conseil son ascendant le
maintien le match va finir à 8 4 grèce
et c'est difficile mais le match est
perdu et je suis qui viennent celles là
peut-être encore une autre filiale de
bull est immense et
il en grand la voie mais toutes parts on
vous l'avait déjà je l'espère geste
d'argent convaincu tout le monde c'est
pas ça fait une belle relance en tout
cas
on vous rappelle qu'on avait pronostiqué
sarine quand même donc déjà on est bien
on est bien sympa mais je vous a fait
une belle relance donc du coup là
c'était pas nous voit peut-être richard
importe revenir je traduis 1
mais justement il y avait 5 4 il y avait
5 4 pour sarine et avant de commencer la
portion 3 plus une et moi je disais donc
ça fait la remarque à jeudi que leur
faute s'ils s'y prend pas le lead en 5
plus une basse est terminé le match prit
pas rentrer chez lui car il regarde ce
qui se passe là il ya 3 0 pour leurs
saris dans tout autre piscine
et oui c'est en train de se profiler
mais ça fait la silla c'est bien quoi
les nations d'un scénario en fait plus
grave en soi même en plus dans le jeu
c'est pas forcément
oui il n'ya pas une différence de plus
15 ans c'est sûr maintenant mais
[Musique]
ça joue sur des petits détails et
particulièrement à mas très très bonne
gestion
du temps de la sarine et puis il trouve
aussi dans les positions difficiles
plein d'angoissé on voit qu'il est
extrêmement fort
les nerfs solides d'un franchement
water là la partie d'avoir il ya
vraiment ce qu'on appelle une poubelle
il a réussi à trouver des ressources
incroyables et la tension et un exam un
attention adam g import hockey h4 il
envoie sur le roi c'est logique comme
quoi puisque le roi blanc il est
beaucoup moins faible que le roi noir h4
dans ses cuves à manger hcap
[Rires]
comme c'est d'ailleurs peut-être plus
c'est bien parce que c'est marrant en
fait je le disais tout à l'heure il a
fait 1-1
c'était des points à 5 kg prend h5
dans une même partie et sarine hélas ce
qui est marrant c'est vrai de
l'ordinateur donne je prends h4 meilleur
coût et j'arrive pas d'apprendre
pourquoi alors quand il veut ils veulent
tous prendre contre 3 et d'amd cas
attaque il a joué sincèrement j'ai dit
gratien gélinas activement et sans ça y
est un shareware je suis complètement
fan de lui là en fait
rien à [ __ ]
mais sur ce match et même les deux parce
que les deux ont plein de concept c'est
vrai je trouve que c'est bon il va qui
32 sur un son sans aucun point mais
franchement les parties elles sont hyper
agréable à regarder il y en a eu peu
justement y avait des parties au chemin
du monde de certains disaient pas le sou
très plate etc voilà vous regardez
s'avancer du blitz c'est un autre maire
mais elles sont elles sont
particulièrement ben c'est parti c'est
que la main franchement à propos on se
régale parce que c'est ça des partis est
bon qu'ils sont
ils font le show quoi tout simplement et
et regardez le roi il est à poil et n'a
rien à [ __ ] figé prend h4 enfin juste
c c'est pourquoi c'est beau ce qu'ils
font et
donc bien sûr c'est un ch'ti question
est ce que vous voyez au super et monde
présent maintient l'équilibré avec des
pièces en or en parle de coordination
des pièces et la
dame à 4h cardin b2s n'ont plus vraiment
de sens mais eux ils arrivent à se
retrouver avec des facilités
calculatoire aussi très importante dans
les deux camps et son hyper fort en
calcul et du coup ils peuvent se
permettre de jouer sur le fil
photo en blitz en blitz ne paraît plus
deux choses
ça reste à ce qui paraît compliqué hamas
est parti je pense que je la la paire
avec les blancs et les noirs
et voilà ça dépend concurrents jouent
kouassi si on est plus forts on peut
s'en sortir mais si on est plus faible
on peut aussi la perdre est très
équilibré mais très
mais très compliqué en même temps à
chaque coup sa peur ça peuvrier
alors qu'ils qui va prendre davantage
cette position manière sereine et il a
toujours toujours comines est en train
de gagner le match il peut se décider
aussi d'aplatir je pense que dans ces
cinq ça sans ce coup là un petit peu il
va laisser faire match nul si tu peux ne
pas perdre votre position maintenant
qu'il ya plus 4 en fait c'est bien je
pense qu'ils dans l'intérêt de sa ring
c'est de jouer solide et
est pas trop laisser de chance pratique
à la la ça c'est à dire
53 ans cette dame âgée quatre dames j'ai
capté dans les calculs et alors que le
roi lors c'est d'abord défendez h6 pur
près d'alger quatre mois c'est ce que
j'aurais fait ce qu'il a oublié soit il
a oublié soit il considérait que ils ont
coûté 1 peut-être cette salle est prévue
elle
voit là mais c'est une prise de risque
et donc je pense que c'est bizarre
comme il ya plus 4 kg solide donc je
pense pas que cet été - sera d'emmener
deux pareils apparaît assez tranquille
maintenant pour
avoir été gardien dans la manche 4 ses
propres aux 600 en veillant bien sûr
aller d'âme des uns d'en prendre trois
ou six mois il fallait voir dan réduite
et d'un projet 3d mais qui sont au fort
que tu vois il avoue t il encore
l'accord ouais c'est ça qui est
incroyable particulièrement c'est pour
ça qu'on disait qu'il a été rapporté
quand même un super match parce que peut
normalement quand tu viens de te faire
avoir plusieurs fois l'impression
gagnant marqué et lui il est peut-être
marqué mais je voudrais envoyer chaque
fois il y en a vu d'autres mais
c'est faux
olivier schaack a plus rien je commence
alors ces questions
là c'est terminé à bientôt il y aura pas
d'avancée serment que la doctrine qui
arrive
qu'un mariage c'était quand même le
quatrième maison carrée jusqu'au 6 mai
ans passés il va pas rater ça ça ira de
passe à
la droite la
salle d'alger six gardes et c'est précis
jusqu'au bout pour faire sourire chaque
attention aux pattes y aura atteint la
frange de marche pas hier encore la
grèce de résulte pour le roi s'en va
puis à nouveau là
ok donc la belge est bien
partie interrompue à celle encore une
pause
à tanger le berns glissement attention
on peut la partie et les joueurs sont
partis en pause encore une fois on fait
ok la pause c'est chaque fois ça chaque
milieu de phases d'accord donc là ça
dure et ça dure 45 minutes de bullet à 2
litres donc là on est à la moitié donc
encore une pause donc le garant vous
repasse une petite page de pub pendant
six minutes et on revient dès que ça
reprend à tout de suite
à tout site
[Musique]
et
on est au menu donc les joueurs c'est un
star
donc je pense là ça va reprendre ici
quand c'est tout le monde ça y est c'est
reparti voilà pile à l'heure
or donc du coup toujours plus trois
jours
pour sarine d'irène par une partie du
coût
et on voit que c'est un rapport conclut
que landaise sabia raconte tout à
l'heure donc à 81,7 à perdre il ya fallu
réussir car l'article qui a eu donc s'il
recommence et joue un stand rôle ce qui
est plutôt étoiles français
écoutons en reste c'est très celui de
somone
sa part son laboratoire et tu vas
essayer d'aller gagner événements
normalement non pas rare d'en ligne à
cinq je vois bien mettre son qu'ailleurs
et 5 assez rapidement
et féret pts 3 cependant le 4 a fait le
5e trois thématiques 1 on va jouer sur
la case 145 arrêté de l'homme et il faut
que le calme soit retirée sans vous
comprendrez fraude est logique à mes
yeux car ces thématiques tout simple
je vais simplement intéressant contre
contre le landaise on est je l'enlève
des dents est en fait attardée qu'un
sport
croire essayant d'élever les fous il ya
un gros froid pour seulement à avoir
plus de pression derrière sur les
bernois re5 et ses seins étaient
intéressés mais moi le plan classique
puisque je vais aussi jouer ses fans que
c'est vraiment une archi plein
après la main sur man show avec son
front f4 s'il va essayer de valoriser
son sont fous ces 1 puisqu'il n'a pas
échangé en a trois il faut qu'il trouve
une autre case voilà c'est chose faite
et il va sans doute construire à 1 et
d'année en fanfare il rapporte arrivé
avec son gros g5 on commence à
reconnaître un
fait partie ça c'est clair
voilà déjà un lien de seuil ne nagerai
fou aux trois c'est marrant parce que si
on joue trois quintés h4 s'est pas
produit faute warfare bon
ok c'est qu'elles le font ce qu il veut
provoquer ces cinq pour
pour revenir un quart du temps un
lorsqu'apparaît ne s'ouvre
ok mais ces sacs se jouer quand même
avec bkb cinq patinoires bon j'ai pas
gpec bon seulement
d'un match 5 place quelle pièce g5 va
arriver connaissant connaissant le
joueur était noir je pense qu'il a même
pris une nouvelle et 5
il a stabilisé le centre vous voyez la
stabiliser ce sens fait après et
maintenant il veut mettre la takkal elle
en place constat mais ce 200 m pour dire
ça mais une réaction centrale en place à
cagnes où cinq pour éviter de trop
prendre l'eau allait le roi sans avoir
de compte roja voilà
sp4 l'image
qu'avait dit elle je crois un peu moins
saccadée 4 à la plus logique
doit vérifier que
moi je n'en sais pas ce qu'ils vérifient
je pensais que j'aurais perdu et a pris
vite en fait ça
dépend de la jouer en tout cas les
quatre et on mange du kf bien entendu
pour elle un tour et on continue avec
m'en vais pas jouer commentaire de temps
prendrait 5 est possible est accusé
trois derrière ça peut faire mal c'est
la fonction si bien justement ça fait
mal c'est un petit peu bizarre ce qu'il
a fait l'avenir sign je pense que la
durée d'un an maintenant
en bon refaire à chaque fois on a pris
le temps est
souvent on voit que signale sarine ne
joue pas tempo c'est qu'il a des
difficultés mais là ça a l'air d'être le
cas
c'est un peu bizarre ce qu'il a fait là
le coin f3 il a voulu se libérer ça je
le comprends c'est encore un petit peu
prématuré
c'est ce qui va arriver un jour d'un
médecin quand vous regardez le garde-fou
décisionnel plongé cette bizarre après
beauregard en souffrance quand même
c'est sûr que richard rapport dans cette
position il avait fait des cistes
on va commencer à menacé pour un blanc a
non d'un prêt 3,6 pour moi c'est pas
il possède de solides un coût aussi
soudé si c'est pour réfuter ces notes
comme ça il va jouer à coude et 6 mai à
savoir quand il n'a pas le choix
il faut aussi qu'on renvoie d'un objet
si c'est pas son idée il faudra prendre
les six et [ __ ] en décembre gagnant
mois ils sont ils sont vraiment le
joueur nie la shoah est nativement voir
s'ils ont joué contre eux c'était pas on
voit ce qui se passerait on prendrait
tous les coups du tennis comme on dit
des plus banales on voit qu'ils sont
vraiment vraiment je crois par contre
franchement owen va pas y penser pour
l'instant
cette action à raison des signaux forts
alors ça se passe mal la can pour le jeu
encore il va tenter tourcoing des cinq
la connaissance non il a pu voir prendre
part au match 2 et vous aussi bah oui là
là là on commence à prendre non pour ce
qu'il m'a tenté peut-être tout reprendre
et 5.7 se sortir de là et la
quasi mort magna tsarine bayer du fou il
ya dommage de tout ce qui peut arriver
il ya toutes les pièces qui arrivent
dessus pour point un traitement arrive
aussi et doit être prise et x factor
première fois trois voies la hiroire de
damages de maths du même souffle a vu le
gars donc franchement heureusement qu'il
avait eu sa femme fort
mais franchement harare charles ray
avoir dès qu'on a dit qu'il prenait un
petit peu l'eau d'égout radics le match
était fini femmes il est revenu là là
mais bon encore une fois j'ai
l'impression que production se passe
bien
classés c'est fou a
donc vraiment harrach
comme d'hab refusé au départ
donc partir en week end à moins de
gamins qui revient à 20,2
g star in là il faut qu'il se
ressaisisse puisque là ça fait quand
même deux parties où il devient en
souffrance
est à +4 qu'il avait quasiment match
gagné mais bon
c'est richard rapporte
way dans le match pour l'instant gagné
énormément de très bonnes parties de
richard rapporte génie à sarine sur les
sortir en jouant plus vite et en étant
plus constant donc est-ce que vous à
quoi sert également de base
faux at war et bien qu'on est dans le
conte c'est d'abord un peu actif mais
bon top juste dame
a aussi inventé de fonctionner tout
objet de repartir non finalement la
russe pour pour répondre à alex aux faux
et sur le solde ça si tu parles du jeu
d'échecs
c'est un jeu compliqué mais là du coup
il ya une heure trente de deux parties
en cinq minutes secondes par coup c'est
un match ensuite il y à 45 minutes de 3
+ hull et ensuite on va avoir la portion
d'une minute plus une seconde barre
d'outils qui débutera à la fin
du temps sur le temps réglementaire à
15,45
dans le peloton qui s'écoula donc du
coup ça un match le score est à 8,6 pour
l'instant pour un genre à un bien est ce
qualificatif en place les quarts de
finale et ce quart de finale qualifié
pour le match des deux américains entre
caruana esso qui aura que je crois le
neuf
le neuf noms
de treize regardiez resentir ariège le
neuf
le lundi 6 6 1 non oui c'est le 9 nov le
9 décembre
jeu d'échecs des prédictions ses fans
cite ainsi d'un truc devant toi ça va
pas mais en fait il faut que tu fasses
des prédictions ça marche bien
non pendant tué le petit point c'est
vrai développe il ya hélas possible et
de faire dame prend à 8 il l'a pas fait
pour fonder deux tours est alors que là
il vient d'avoir une petite trace
tactique à nouveau
donc avec son fils adam alors ils
arrivent plus à la place tout simplement
manger v6 cavale yeux de roy f136 roi
prend à eux deux ils avaient un pur
moment avec un pont car elle fera
mauvais fou je pense à fait possible et
la place là il a décidé de sacrifier la
dame pour en fait pour un cavalier une
tour et après c'est le matériau sur le
pion des cinq dont la carrière dépend
des gatti ida fort le fou 17 qui est pas
terrible et structures noir qui est
assez intéressant pratique hamas afin de
masquer aux flyers on voit qu'il ya des
fifties matériel etc mais il ya quand
même les arguments pour les blancs si la
schl akon ah voilà ils veulent et les
noirs vont pouvoir rebondir sur lacaune
à la ja de damas trois et voilà moi
c'est gênant du coup
il aurait mieux valu réussir à faire un
tour à 5 ou quelque chose comme ça ils
vont se passer la nuit ouais
bon maintenant on voit clairement qu'il
souffre est atteinte du foie f5 la série
non
cinq salles à sa leur forme ouais bon ok
il termina des orques ont des seins ah
c'était ça la pointe mais est ce qu a
appris aux prises
ouais et là ça va être très chaud
en fait juste fou grand bain pour qu'on
avait buté fou des trois attaquants et
valier mois qui arrivent ça alors toi
même ça alors quand même
assez se ressaisit au sérieux quand je
mange ses trois c'est un bon nom or en
fait là richard rapporte il a joué très
vite à un moment il s'est enflammé hyper
rapidement mais il aurait pu intéressant
plus qu'il avait fait mais loin derrière
il a pas trois sur m6 la dia on voit que
les temps va se se réduisent c'est comme
un c'est l'étrange saint-claude de l'âme
parce qu'il aurait pu aurait pu jouer
donc avec nous et vous exemple le moins
intéressant je préférais 1 mais je pense
qu'elle ait un incident a voulu montrer
qu'il avait bu et qui y est je pense une
part de bluff aussi danser dans ces
parties là par moments quand même bien
le 10 mais on le sait qu'on ne part km
dames à ce moment là je veux dire t'es
peut-être dans quoi tu as été bon c'est
un coup de poker j'avais vu rouge avec
des potes ya longtemps et j'ai un pote
qui enfin il y avait dix revers un mec
comme un tapis
avec juste hauteur d'un pays à rien et
il gagne parce qu'après il chassa river
la belle-de-mai qu'à la fin il lui dit
mais pourquoi tu colles de ta vie il dit
ben je crois que tu monte et pas le
punch drunk colle avec rien en fait mais
avec une hauteur parce qu'ils pensent
que le moment est en fait le mec pour te
dire ça prenait à partie de poker axa et
prince même pas il attribue catch avec
hauteur dames nancy jusque là mais qu'en
fait juste il jouait au hasard
et voilà mais là une fois que vous avez
fait la dame je pense que comique quand
même le bluff bien la mairie oui alors
oui mais si tu veux c'est aussi une
réaction instinctive dans le sens tu
vois c'est le mec vois tu es surpris et
tu veux je veux y aller et c'est à dire
peu repris il a fait accélérer un petit
peu sa décision n'aurait peut-être plus
réfléchi longtemps en temps normal l'aï
obligé de balancer un peu trop vite des
choses mais est-ce que ça a marché non
c'est des échecs ouais c'est pas le
poker et du cou malheureusement dans la
lah ya pas de luis à peu par virer
viré donc du coup du coût d'un gain de
sari dont qui repasse à plus trois
équipes françaises
ok on passe la française
est beaucoup d échanges c'est un
petit avantage pour les blancs sans trop
de risques donc c'est un sas tarage
poussette ouais c'est pas mal à la mode
et c'est une très solide
mais donc c'est plutôt une
bonne
position pour pour sa rive qui lui joue
pour ne pas perdre maintenant sachant qu
il a qui l'accablent trois points
d'avance il va essayer de limiter un
petit peu le jeu de l'adversaire il n'y
a pas de prendre tous les risques au
niveau là ça va rien
c'est les noirs doivent essayer de créer
des choses et je suis pas sûr que le
rapport seront fréquents pour sa
position
bah oui par rapport au contexte du match
com voilà rien c'est difficile sinon
c'est une très belle ouverture d'un
point de vue
d'un point de vue pratique le problème
pour gagner c'est que ça va être ça va
être très difficile déjà déjà pour
gagner de cette position avec les noirs
c'est possible mais 2 1 ça va être long
parce que la position c'est une pétition
lancée
donc ça va être long et il n'a pas
beaucoup de temps pour
recoller au score et
et puis ces mêmes pages que la gagne
appelle la gagne 3 points de retard il
faut qu'ils commencent à 1
à mettre les bouchées doubles
la loi qui
il a pas de porc doit gagner cette
partie
savoir se reproduire sans doute
est positive des petits problèmes
il doit activer son fou il doit activer
sa majorité
il a le fou ça échange de pièces le
cavalier qui qui infirme un peu dominé
un cabinet qui la passionne et pastrami
va dégager ouais ils représentent 5 des
faits mineurs d'ailleurs si le 5 1 jour
et si lieu de progresser
en un sens elle joue bien à richard à
part ça c'est au final la obtenir un
petit petit quelque chose d améliorer sa
position puisque cela il ya les deux
tours sur la colonne des majors il ya
plus qu il ya moins de pression ce côté
là et j'ai cinq excellents les veut
ouvrir la position
le modèle de finale à tout à toute
vitesse non c'est que là franchement
c'est impressionnant ouais c'est super
c'est un placement refuge nous a dit que
c'était un enfant pasqua
il sait jouer techniquement aussi que la
technique mamba quant à 1 710
normalement tâche est complet quand même
s'est ouvert de 7 ou faire mais c'est
impressionnant de voir cette finale où
il n'y en pas grand chose pour pour les
noirs
de la transformer comme ça y'a rien il
est 15 h 30 h pour les noirs il faut
qu'ils arrivent ans et ses cinq jours de
cavale et qui est rien comme à ses
déclarations passées qui a été créée
voilà le pion que là peut-être fou 17
pour
garder le cap d'un cameron de -15 bessin
et va essayer d'avancer un jour ça qu'il
prononce pas facile à faire
quand tous âges 5,5
un tour le caresser de monter le roi
j'écoute pas dans les caisses 5 d'abord
on réussissait un jour ou 5
mais ça reste stoïque chez lez lens
cavaliers il est là on croirait 3 sa
case est mauvais on défend h 2
on a ça va pas être si facile de passer
quand même donc il faut travailler pour
améliorer sa position petit à petit il
fait à 6 pour un jour pouvoir car wade
6e 5 des 6 500 pour être le bon plan et
faire plus attention à des c4 des des
cochonneries tactique c'est pas tout
bien construire son jeu aussi à tout le
temps en éveil tactique
qu'est ce que j'ai essayé de la jouer il
fera son avis il est jeune on comment je
pense que oui c'est le jeu pour lui
d'essayer de jouer cette position basse
il a joué tout ça se pense que c'est
pour essayer de la plage maintenant cela
il comme à -3 il n'a pas trop le temps
de 20 une nulle
en fait il reste six minutes de blink et
après et après une demi-heure de budget
qu'il a moins 3
donc du coup il a une position comme il
a un petit avantage je pense qu'ici il
doit essayer de la gagner salement
anti pressing par contre c'est dur de
savoir comment la comment passer quoi
parce qu'on peut se dire la sinne
c'est-à-dire série noire qui peuvent
faire tourner un peu le roi blanc va ici
mais il ya rien de concret voilà tour
cinq tours à chaque il a un peu mieux
qu'il ya des petits ces cas qui arrive
mine de rien comment on va gérer ces
quatre là c'est pas c'est pas ça
voilà une amie bout de quatre mois il a
pris une décision
il était gêné par un c4 qui allait
arriver
là le seul plan des noirs c'est
valoriser leurs points forts aussi 7,6
avec le 55
réussir à perdre ça
compliqué encore
mc rae nord plus un petit peu en danger
autant et maintenant c'est une finale
deux pions
et à l'air nul mais on sait bien en
pratique que ça peut à chaque coup de
petits pions à une grosse incidence
dans les blancs qui font g4 qui sait se
créer un pion pas ch mais aussi le
public les pions e m6 vont très très
vite
vous envoyer ce sens mis d'accord alors
à voir que j'écarte ne plaisait pas
l'ordinateur avec h projet 4 qu'il vient
et qui donnait bien il y avait à changer
qu'à trois points d'écart et rockabilly
chaque 100 dos et moi avec tous les
échecs on est un petit peu de temps game
sur le roi répond à la mort de fiction
mais c'est un cas classique de des
finales de pioche même à très haut
niveau
même dans les parties de grands
champions il ya eu des erreurs il faut
pas croire les finales de pions sont
simples
après sony d'un à cinq secondes de la
formule 1 oui c'est pour ça qu'il a fait
sien bêtise d'ailleurs de feu qui wemmel
sujet la pollution à cinq secondes juste
il carbure
jusque là il ya plein de possibilités
que je f5 troadec à droite rue des sarts
qui ont tourné un petit peu et essayé de
la jouer
pas simple
ouais
on va voir si le temps de voir son temps
s'égrenait
match nul donc les ir est je pense une
seule partie dans ce dans ce format
parce qu'il est troisième avec renault
est toujours trois qu'on avance toujours
pour
fournir de sarine de belles parties
encore de richard rapporté bien partie
de nuit elles sarine de demeurer sous et
franche ans richard rapporte il a fait
une partie encore un c'est clair c'est
le droit qui les a moins deux fois pour
saturer et chacun au grand miroir plein
droit
on voit que va voir ça les
sort l'artillerie drum
donc ok vous et théâtre
sont pas manger il est bien sûr tout et
on sera pas accueillir je crois que ça
paie là se trouve la
face à stéphane et contre attaque
palmyre ou quelque chose comme ça c'est
ce truc ne pas répondre je ne vivais
well as et je crois qu'on est vraiment
dans les richards apportent leur savoir
et leur apprendre à savoir une
bouilloire à la fin du string
[Rires]
si on fait une interview en français ça
me va
et le même prendre et ça joue un petit
peu comme kia est cette fois tombé 4 je
connais rien du tout la rue
du match 3
à 3,5 m aussi ça a du sens à ce qu'a
fait le fou proches que j'ai francs et
après je pouvais faire un coup d'arrêt
reprend 1,95 m x bow pion au centre
ouais après là il peut peut-être juste
ramener ce concours
exposition ce diesel mais qu'après faut
aussi mais qu'est ce qu'ils pensent d'un
truc du genre tout problème 3.3 et au 3e
juste produire
il démarre avec sculptures ou réduits le
problème c'est que je vais vous prendre
3 j'ai quand même les deux fous or c'est
intéressant franchement c'est vraiment
l'idée rigolo parce que c'est une chose
eh ben tu vois ta terre dans perspicace
c'est pas parce que ça s'est joué je
mets ya les deux fous dans le foot
recasement jeu maintenant vont interdire
donc à un pion de plus il soutient un
peu bizarre mais c'est bon je peux
travailler entre 3 à 4 enfants rock et
il ya quand même eu de comprendre mais
deux des six grands a tué 2 aurait du
sens
voilà c'est réglé et maintenant la
valorisation de cette position pour les
blancs c'est de réussir
sortir le fouet un poids qui est le plus
gros problème de leur position s'ils
s'emparaient de la structure c'est
surtout ce fou distinctif qui ne
possèdent pas les noirs et qu'il faut
justement valorisé pour faire mal au
noir est là maintenant je serai bien
quelque chose comme des cages vous
madame et charles frey fin
il n'aura de toute façon maintenant
sortir le fouet par la boîte sympa mais
que des 4,7 à mme b 5 c1 poupe à
hollywood à na li
d'échangés et dames et chevaliers cap
d'abord pour éviter maintenant ça
viendra sans doute là bien sûr qu'elle
va bien
enfin trois ans après dans des 5 type
d'idées c'est dommage
malheureusement le sacrifice et enfin 2
[Musique]
way est en train de devenir un peu moi
ou ceara rouge adam les
les pièces blanches ont retrouvé
naturellement l'enfant dans 15 ans
tourcoing 17 chez les enfants
donc alors qu'est ce qu'il a vu sur f5
je suis empressé écoulée donc vous c'est
bien habana partie des trois plus qu'une
apprend partir avec kimi page de pub
encore l'homme soir avant d'entamer la
dernière portion de bullet il y aura une
demi heure on les plus sûres
on sait que myrtille sarine maintenant
est en grande difficulté puisque déjà
mon imposition et par abonné en plus les
mâles autant une tron 2 mois et à chaque
fois que ça a été le coeur des fois il a
réussi à s'en sortir mais c'était pas
pour rien il était en grande difficulté
la perte de fonctions plus ou puisqu'ils
jouent un coup comme assiste donc c'est
pas trop quoi faire
là maintenant est ce que richard
rapportent avoir un poste va réussir à
ses vertus et là il ya des prisons de
partout
vous mettez en rogne la dame babou gf2
comme on attend d'être fermement
estimé que dans ces cas car peu importe
et ça commence à être absolument rien
devient
de plus en plus folle et blanc une
peinture qui a tout cassé oui on voit
que c'est plus agréable pour les blancs
mais ça peut se retourner sur leurs
positions ouais évidemment
le maintien de la pression sur le coupé
4c important et on ferait bien un petit
ces trois athlètes
vont mal à l'espace prévention c'est la
tour et forcé pour ces 3 lorsque j'ai
même d'amener en prison jusqu'en 2002 je
ne sais pas ce qu'il a vu ou pas aux
camélias 5 paire de dames j'ai pas de
gaz c'est terrible
gilbert jones a fait plusieurs fois à la
fatigue aussi herman pour des joueurs
exceptionnels comme ça mais là c'est
bizarre ça a mal tourné cette histoire
bon il va continuer parce que peut-être
wen dans le mécénat dans la partie en
fait donc dedans donc force continue en
face à ces dernières parties 54 secondes
c'est ça c'est pour ça que j'ai envie de
confirmer la dame en noir c'est beaucoup
surtout qu'en fait vous pouvez vraiment
c
c'est beaucoup trop dur c'est bizarre
qu'il est
là il a un fou pour la dame d'avant
d'oeuvre incroyable et
c'est une nouvelle fois le scénario
convient maintenant depuis un milieu
d'après midi stéphane à chaque fois ils
voyaient une super partie de richard
rapporté aux moments clés on a
l'impression qu'il va gagner banyan
sarine défend défend et des fois et aidé
par richard laporte qui se craquèle n'y
a pas de mots là sur le coup il doit pas
être très content ce qui s'est passé
c'est simple
bon du coup
+4 pour pour sari les indices et demie 6
ennemis et donc une petite pause de six
minutes donc on vous remet une page de
pub et on revient dans six minutes puis
cyril je pense qu'il y avait pas grand
chose sur la fourchette voilà on veut
partir à pose là dessus d'ailleurs je
vais je crois que c'est baptiste
barcelone m'a demandé de remettre la
partie de sa vie tout à l'heure où
où il ya eu beaucoup plus rares je suis
là mais quand le chat en même temps je
passe en pub et je te mets là le la
mancha a tout de suite
salut
[Musique]
et nous sommes revenus et on a perdu qu
ils vivent c'est bon je suis toujours au
niveau du son en tout cas non c'est la
caméra qui marchait plutôt qu'il se
vendait tout va bien
dans le coup je pense qu'on va avoir en
quelques secondes
donc la troisième section qui va être ou
le bullet donc on a
trente minutes de bullet pour finir ce
match donc pour l'instant
ni à sa une à quatre points avance sur
les rapports de ses demi à six et demi
et ça a commencé là dans quelques
secondes
donc pronostics formule est
moi je vois richard à je vois venir
sarine largement devant
bon ça va hein dire mais j'ai joué entre
les deux camps bullet et
et ça arrive mais beaucoup moins
prenable que rapport c'est pas
mon expérience la commission actuelle
c'est car dira-t-il et il est vraiment
peu un plan dedans quand même richard
rapport taxi lui vient de lui arriver
c'est pas mal voire moins quatre en deux
ans alain marty genk est bon normalement
ça doit pas lui arriver klein
il est bon en fait s'il commence par
deux petites victoires rapporte qui peut
revenir dans un match niveau confiance
niveau ça a pris un gramme demi heure
quand même de viande ou blesse c'est
quand même pas mal il ya beaucoup de
parties à jouer
allez c'est parti cavalière trois récits
de femmes enfants photo a même pas
le gros bazar ça va très vite pour vous
non pas s'il est légal donc convoi
sarine 3256
c'est juste un mur stratosphérique
et rapport qu'il ya un trait qui
impriment en persan a commis 41 ans a
fait fort
vous disais que métier sarine grand
favori c'est pas pour rien
donc on va voir ce qui se passe
nous pas commenter les courses
difficiles du blitz et on va commander
nic maman j'ai grandement les temps au
tour
sert pour venir cru un peu fou d'un
autre vous voyez ça jouer à fond la
caisse j'essaie d'avoir des bonnes
pièces et après trente et une tactique a
normalement c'est un vecteur
et surtout pas perdre de temps
ouais donc la honte de voir un petit
double tour sur la peine ces problèmes
en valeur un hiver où il ya un regard
des gros ver ou de neamt sarine il va
monter se disent
isolation des murs à perdre a aidé à
gagner
il va jouer vite et tournez tournez
tournez
énormément ils risquent pas grand-chose
de théâtre n'ont pas indiqué abel ces
cinq amendes et ça c'est intéressant
dans cette fois kim batterie
pour garder sa manière les pièces
vraiment il ya un problème du foot et
d'eau pour les blancs ce nom c'est le
problème
général de la position vous aimez
richard un temps d'essayer de travailler
cette position
de tête mène le cavalier f5 en d6 et
travailler sur les cases fascisme pas 3
si les petits des petites tactiques non
là c'est assez normal peut-être qu'à 10
6 après cas et c'est 4 on va d'abord
échangé ainsi on peut on va peut-être
peut-être donner l'heure le fou comme
lecavalier genre permet bien
voilà on voit qu'ils se dirigent aurait
cassé car il améliore les pièces ouais
si plus pour richard rapporte peuvent
alors une nouvelle fois très bien joué
mais niel sarine on sait bien qu'il va
se battre
le muc moins de gras c'est une super
maman
c'est ça qui a applaudi ce que mais il a
beau très bien joué on sait bien que ça
suffit pas de bien jouer
on doit à ce titre intéressant
faisait d'ailleurs
il n'ya pas si longtemps préféré la
position vous voyez ça va trop vite de
tous âges on va préférer la position des
noirs assez largement et maintenant
c'est beaucoup moins claire
l'affrontement a préféré les voilà la
dame dans la région classée au taf et
funk complètement d'accord on va la dame
b cette
mission d'un précipice
je voulais garder ça pour une bonne idée
c'est très long mais on s'est fait
rentrer la hi hi hi
ils doivent partout
le cas a été jouée en sorte qu'on ait
besoin d'un temps sec à
mazamet
dame s'essayait légère apprend à parler
il est sous une pression trop importante
il avait dominé toute la partie
quasiment et dans le money time on voit
que des capeas et en
sari n'est imprenable et en fait
c'est sûr ça qui fait la différence
attention quand je
ris et il sait faire une fois neame
sarine se fait un peu retourné le royal
ait plus de temps il revient au sein ce
qui est du cas est menacée matin à jeun
en 2011 il ya neuf mois
il n'y a pas de droit et maxime est
bon bah c'est pas si mal pour richard
laporte puisqu'il était pas lancinante
et recoller un mort c'est reparti pour
pleinement aïe aïe aïe donc nous sommes
un parti qui dure cinq minutes à marcel
rien donc ça veut dire non plus on peut
essayer de penser qui va risquer encore
quelques points cinq parties
on a les chances pour richard attend
blanc qui va bientôt jouer pour
l'honneur qu'il n'arrive pas à gagner
une partie rapidement
non je reste quand même que que tous ces
syndicats d'enseignants président on est
assez d'accord avec toi c'est vrai
puisque c'est on voit que c'est le seul
problème ou si elle a eu dans les partis
mais bon il fait des trucs une très
bonne chose mais je
pense qu'il a
c'est fait vous
le fou le faire l'événement donné parce
que fout c'est quand y avait des singles
comme hyper dans une pièce il a décidé
de sacrifier
wilaya on peut dire que les antilles
total de pas mal
mais on s'est complètement on est en
train de commencer à montrer des signes
de faiblesse après c'est très difficile
un cadeau vous avez vu c'est une loterie
mais
on voit neame sarine depuis le début de
plus tard en fait moments chauds comme
cerise et ses 35 ans il arriva à jouer
aux échecs il y avait eu un match en
compétition ces quelques années
c'était attendu à toulouse fin
et où dix femmes quand même dans ces
quelques mois
est bon à cam ward humains romance et
ses coins et anglais s'il est vraiment
un vol et je crois que le score c'est un
truc du genre
25 à croire comme ça et enfin c'est le
passé depuis sa carrière on se sait pas
ce que ça reste que du blitz mais c'est
important quand il prend une grosse
raclée à ces souris passion la paix
incarcéré liu
et là on voit que c'est une énorme
souffrance pour richard rapport mais bon
avec la crise de temps tu peux arriver
c'est une qualité net de moi
pouvoir un tout petit peu pénible a
gagné d'opposition surtout et grands
secondes même celles plus un
mais on voit quasiment déclaré nyan win
vainqueur s'il vient à bout de cette
position
une vingtaine de minutes et en fait tu
vois le match quasiment perdu on lui
dire parce
dans l'agriculture p1 une partie dure en
france cinq minutes
imparties l'état points
il faut qu'ils viennent d'en tracer
maintenant le miracle le miracle rien et
puis déjà il faut
il faudrait ne pas perdre cette position
parce qu'ils sont là quasiment
impossible la gagne encore moins bon en
boxe et ce fut là je suis à bientôt
abandonner riches amateurs
série noire pour les 8 ans et 6 mois là
et là ça va être réglé malheureusement
et donc du coup avec cinq points de
retard je pense c'est par milliers que
je pense qu'avec 22 minutes ils n'auront
pas le temps de faire c'est parti donc
ça va être intéressant de voir dans
cette situation il a été assez patent il
s'est prit car pas mal de sales coups de
ce soir rapport il a réussi comme à
rebondir dès fois de manière assez
étonnante vraiment est à -4 sur le banc
c'est foutu des revenus à moins 2 et en
plus la qualité de ces partis et et
bonne foi non c'est clair ils jouent
plus tard là il est vraiment comment
mais ils avaient évidemment des
problèmes dans
en finition des partis de québec qui
répond à 6,5 ou non il y avait il faut
aussi savoir
si ce faux seins ce qui était
réservé à l'ouverture d'antennes z
concept plaît aussi c'est un aveu gamin
aux six
paires de fou pour les blancs centre
pour les blancs et cavalli que les 15 gr
sur les blancs 11 et 5 ans et 6 points 3
voilà quelques pions dacquois qui sont
vraiment en prison mais préfère avoir
des bonnes pièces que prendre le pion
qui redonne d'événements sur
l'adversaire il ya sont là les 4 des 6
et 5 ap si ça va être
très difficile
bon ça y est cela revient à 4 moi j'aime
bien accord
avec l'idée de chasser petits cavaliers
et à quoi je pourrais finir
maintenant il n'est plus en train
devrait plutôt en train de le
verrouiller à petite amélioration lente
est un petit pourrait faire
prochainement
vous devez
trouver un et à 80 jours par an mais
l'époque atteint 100 mais je pense à nos
bonnes pièces voilà ce que dit génial
sarine il a fallu laisser passer ainsi
même ça va tenter de la mi-temps du hors
plus à envoyer un peu leur la
problématique la rivière rapporte il est
un peu sorti quand même de
de sa position difficile il a aussi a
passé ses cavaliers de manière
intelligente du bloqueur boubekeur bien
voilà sa victoire sur le terrain lié
la tourette emprise cavaliers
d'entreprise doit très vite aurait fait
pression sur les recettes
tout débute à retrouver six imagine dans
ce domaine sur le
marseillais voilà pourquoi un si ce
voyage on verrouille way surprend et ça
y est il va faire
il va jouer à fond maintenant pour 1 500
personnes c'est possible ah oui c'était
facile mais c'est pas à saint-cloud
ponts et ouvrages cloud et il a choisi
la variante mois il a quatre secondes
donc il n'ya pas de la tactique mais il
a une très très belle finale maintenant
et petit noël qu'on ne sait pas plus
qu'hier et cela grâce aux promesses un
carrefour 17 ans et il a donné deux
pions sur 7 sans doute pas mieux mais
bon c'est bien fait c'est pas si grave
parce que tu as le temps passé au final
bc sarah complètement d'accès rapport
qui ne viennent pas c'est parti au final
gagner offert un nul ici pour ça il en
fait même
sa une régime ans qui aurait préféré
gagner connaissant ce genre de joueur il
veut tout gagner ouais allez savoir sur
un mobile 2-1
aller
voyez ça va très très vite mais en tout
cas effectivement comme le dit stéphane
center pas dans ce cas parce que c'est
un coup il découle
sylvie roy ou deux sur la la il était
jusqu où les fous et du pouvoir on va
venir dams est ok
bon vous le soir parce qu'ils sont
graves cas du tout non maintenant ça va
être ça va trop vite on n'a pas le temps
d'analyser 20,0 ans est mort mais pour
nous ça va trop vite un
sale et ses
îles de jouer en face de nous un bon
point
beau spectacle
et nous mêmes une envie de passer en
justice à ce partout rue d'arras moi
c'est du rap c'est dur
novak richard rapporte son envie roi
sont quand même
mal goupillé
after the line a mis à descendre sur ce
camp sans relâche
et l'autre six cuvées les intéressent en
a peur de jouer à 5
l'idée que 71 des portes rendent en
france et 5 mai 5 mai
de tin man is ça existe toujours là il
va le faire sur nous on va tous croient
eux ok
c'est pas les syriens mais il s'y lie à
un peu large pour
leurs
débuts à la mémoire dynamique capable
ces réintroductions
coup pour coup quand même pas un triste
pour toi totor parapente et parfois d'un
v6 population sur le 3 km pour 8 qui va
intensifier la pression ils apprendront
aussi non madame des quatre manches de
la loi ont fait le spectacle zaia
a et puis on voit que
il est en difficulté maintenant richard
rapport je pense que il sait que le
match est perdu donc et les nuances à
rennes i continue pour se faire plaisir
et richard rapportent ils continuent
pour juste l'odeur mais c'est difficile
c'est bien ça sans savoir ce que pense
moring là c'est un peu moche d'ailleurs
reliant vraiment arrêter
la torture mais il faut continuer
c'était à l'ied après une grosse raclée
comme toi on en apprend à
1.715 secondes
la petite menace 5 se voir défendre leur
simplifier sa lettre aux pièces sur la
vie en événements et profits est
conforme avec
les 500 ça peut bien manger après 3 il
sécurisé comme ça sa dame reste dedans
il y en a pour à la une un dessin qui
lie aussi constant
et regardez là on voit ça rapporte avec
22 secondes contre 5 mai s'est perdu à
nouveau c'est encore cher à +6
il est retardé le lancement il ya plus
ou moins
ça fait vraiment
500 points remonte à lundi déjà il ya
plus le temps matériel et au delà de ça
ça commence et là on va voir
la série neal baer rouille faire de faux
problème
c'est compliqué compliqué cette partie
vous voyez maintenant ça soit pour on
devient
plus commentateurs commentateur de foot
là ses fans dans ce genre situation sur
le bullet c'est pas facile d'en placer
une tellement ça va la trouver vraiment
expliqué malheureusement tout cela
est en réalité le match c'est
parce qu'il faut monter voir juste pour
power pour way et puis la qualité de jeu
qu'il a déployé ses comme on dit c'est
pas payer mon message est souvent un
jeu cette année de prendre à payer donc
voilà c'est maintenant qu'on le sort et
lui laisser faire parce qu'il mérite pas
de perdre pas de site comme ça
le sport et du tracé vert franchement
dans ce match
la qualité de jeu toujours de déchets
quand même rapport à
mieux
faire
passer
on est complètement d'accord là dessus
il a montré beaucoup de choses qu'on
prendre l'aventage faire souffrir son
adversaire mais pas finalisé voilà ça
compte aussi mais c'est vrai que c'est
un peu frustrant
on voit que ni à tsarine en fait c'est
je pense le ce qui prévaut en orbite il
arrive à jouer très rapidement en
gardant un niveau de qualité correcte et
et richard rapporte il a super bien joué
mais un moment quand le temps s'effrite
voilà c'est tout son jeu qui c'est qui
s'écroule et c'est ce qu'il a fait mieux
que les merengues ont pour l'instant il
fait fruits parfumés
le manque de temps souvent c'est le
moment où ça commence bien coût 2 bon ça
peut encore se passer pas mal de choses
il avait oublié je pense
l'afflux ces quatre verrous et va ça y
est à part ces quatre
saveurs en suivant des 16 quand même
poste de gardien où vivent à l'air bien
toi confiance voilà
non c'est trop difficile
décision rennais à mort
pour ces six auteurs pour ainsi pour
attirer les gars pour cette enseigne
à rentrer en jeu
ce massif en bas
par rapport à
[Musique]
ces espaces ne gagne pas à rome des
canards
voilà maintenant on va très bien se
passer imaginez
la petite tentative sera pas suffisant
le fond blanc va pouvoir prendre tous
les pions et en plus cela il suffit de
se créer l'orage passé récemment à
gagner mais on versait si vous-même
basse voilà
moins que les 6
à 8 ans
est le joueur avec
richard rapporte il est à plus de deux
mille sept cent cinquante lots comme
vous le savez donc c'est quand même dur
pour un joueur du tout premier plan se
prendre l'a7 fans pour moi il y aurait
12 minutes de calvaire parce que là
maintenant
les défaites s'enchaînent histoire
saveurs ready set et demi s'est produit
vers port c'est quand même c'est quand
même ouais quatre top 15 mangas
et top 15 mangas c'est quand même ternat
quelque chose est cependant que
ces
personnes avec une pièce
administrative comme une m1 richard
rapporte voilà le fond sunnite anti
peinture
pour cointrin assez fort pour un césar
en coupant un récit sur l'épousé 3%
bon là ça commence à être quelque chose
en et vous avez vu on n'a même pas le
temps une apprécié et s'est déjà
elle a réussi à lui coller une aide à là
ça va lui faire du bien au moral nous
souhaitons maintenant on me dit qu'on
était plutôt produire la sarine
mais
à ça ferait du bien de voir un peu
richard de gagner comme on souhaite pas
accueillir arty ou pour que je retrouve
mon état je crois points
dames c'est hui autour preuve cette
ouais ça perd de la position
gestion de l'année la couronne ya de ça
y est complètement raté sa partie moi je
pense que maintenant il
sait gagnant il a été un peu plus léger
sur 7 ha sur cette partie des 5 et 6
il a vraiment perdu cette partie en
quasiment deux minutes mais
il a été efficace
les comprend bon voilà
je change tout m francis attention à toi
je serai
sentait bien que ce serait lequel vers
les stands être pionner
sarine qui pouvait abandonner au bon en
fait l'association végétal a tendu la
joue je viens c'est rémy sait qu'il doit
faire durer il va perdurer mais vole à
7.9 ans je pense pas il ya eu des
pressions où il avoue la répéter la
nulle comme ça sans trop bon alors que
la camorra par exemple il aurait jusqu'à
maintenant une tradition
donc je pense que nous en fait si ce
gamin je pense que tu te rends là ça
fait ma femme franchement
elle est belle partie après partie de
chat rapport ici qui
il est toujours longue balle mais au
moins qu'ils aient qui se bat
malgré le score très sévère et la
poursuit
proposer de très posé avec un pic à way
en tout cas de la sarine l'a vu la casse
qui vient de temps il va il est reparti
sur un double front kétou stéphane
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus tranquille
on va pas pas s'exciter
et ça hyper rapide mais ça y est vide à
l'ania sarine un tout petit plus de
placement de pièces
c'est assez agréable
il va faire tourner les pièces améliorer
les pièces tranche de massy c'est le
point peu chiant qu'il ya une âme p2 de
dettes
au
ménage pas les seules données aidé à me
soit 1 et voilà la riche rapport qu'on
savait qu'il était complètement il
vivait avant le direct sans doute mais
là ils auront des moulins à vent le long
bon enfant il sait qu'il a perdu
c'est d'abord du bail s'amuse bassem abu
leila ils vont faire des bulles est
comme à la maison j'ai envie de dire
c'était le matin après une brillante
victoire de faire tout de suite comme ça
c'était
un peu moi j'ai apprécié représailles
les parties d'attac voyeur il veut
attaquer le roi il veut il veut mater
son adversaire brillant matheou perdre
voila voila mode de richert rapport
bon le match est perdu là ils s'amusent
ils essaient de l'élection un petit peu
là maintenant l'heure
du berger quand même c'est quand même
c'est du troll encore 5 minutes 7
minutes pour pouvoir voir comment
comment les joueurs jouent en cadence
ultra rapide et là le débat est assez
déséquilibré
la voix temps des incas relief singles
richard rapporte revoir un claque
quelque part et la rocqué on sait qu'il
y avait m en face aux attaques de mars
voilà maintenant c'est vrai que c'est
bon c'est une bonne position pressing
local relief trac mais c'est vrai que là
avec cinq ans chacun le match plié
6 que ces murailles du c'est l'avant
dernière ou l'avant-dernière partie
ouais je pense le seul avoué
avoir
pris un mélange de on aime bien le blanc
ici je pense cavaliers tient comme
monstrueux ça entre vie qui joua cas des
petites ressources à gaza qui fait
derrière
on l'a vu dans des positions comme cela
avant tout la famille résister
et qui sont horribles ici son rôle parce
que
ils prennent pression une question de
pression et avait quand même à as à se
défendre c'est c'est la règle rapidement
le
niveau du joueur c'était hallucinant
particulièrement diane sagnier m'a
beaucoup professionnelle dans ce
registre là c'est à dire qu'on a dit que
richert apporte avait quand même très
bien joué tout l'après midi au final ils
seront quand même de gros ce matin parce
que venir la sarine il arrive à jouer
des positions où
ses limites abandon et il pose des
petits problèmes quoi
et pousse c'est aussi une qualité en
pratique la nièvre d'insistance avait
retourné son invention cavalière cinq
ans on connaît ce long de l'histoire
ça fait hyper mal il se bat énormément
et franchement c'est
c'est très impressionnant très
intensément là tous les deux en fait un
mais franchement tu vois le score il est
très sévère mais c'est un très très bon
rythme quand même aujourd'hui
mais bon c'est un peu triste pour pour
rapport parce que fo christian est
vraiment trop sévère
bon
ça reste
ça va ce que les publics c'est du budget
on est sympa du tout à la glisse de
diane lane aussi c'était pas des
gueuletons vers voir d'abord
à deux des six points et fils vivant
dans le carré
là c'est quand même le domaine on va
créer encore un pion pas cf si je dis
pas de bêtises stéphane c'est assez joli
les besoins qui va faire jaser car tfk
parfait ouais ouais ou l'inversé soir
mais là il va faire des cartes ces beaux
moyens donnés pions soyez poli à la main
faisait coiffer retour à soi si on a une
masse en construction dans sa bande on
n'en fait plus des surprises cette fois
je voulais montrer ça me fait
malheureusement ces enchères
ouais ça c'est un thème important au
plus ouais c'est super bien en plus ça
monte ça
donc du coup alors celle là c'est
possiblement la dernière partie ce qui
vous prend et cd-rom
3.85 à l'étranger 4 3 et fils
voilà pour délire
bouaghi et plus quand même là richard
laporte on peut se dire ça
vous avec la moi
même canaliser simple sa boîte avait vu
mon âge
il est complètement complètement perdu
mais c'est marrant voir un joueur aussi
fort perdu mais ça rien de public c'est
du bullet le format du tournoi fait que
c'est spectaculaire
hélas bien la paire de roues la petite
faiblesse structurelle
ouais c'est bien con c'est serena n'a
pas trop dire cela malheureusement mais
pourquoi le match était vraiment en ce
moment les parties d'en manger beaucoup
un géant qui fait ainsi pas vous mentir
moselle on y sert
finalement qu'à partir d'un mois mouassa
facem bull est pas ce qu avait déjà trop
d'écart pour que ça soit un rigolo mais
le reste est exceptionnel parce que là
c'est vraiment du pain c'est
de l'acharnement quoi oui et puis avec
richard rapport comme on sent bien
qu'ils vont encore perdre cette partie
parce qu'il dit voilà il a arrêté les
glands peu plus je pense
il a arrêté très tôt
pour s'offrir encore une intime au monde
magique aïe aïe aïe on n'a même plus le
temps voire est parti il a déjà perdu
rappel du score 17 ennemis huit et demi
kyling et le score de sarine contre
gries tout et tout comme trois fois
champion du monde de blitz cédé 15 15 me
à 10 me donc là on est là c'est encore
plus sévère
l'ancien lyonnais a rapporté des cas
pareils s'en fiche elle a envie de mater
niall sarine pour finir en beauté
d'ailleurs le rouge de collation très
avantageux on fait une bouche quand même
con finir
elles vendent la sarine encore t'as vu
c'est un arbre sur ce qu'il a trouvé
pour aplatir un peu
la position et c'est clair franchement
pour city arrive
c'est pas clair du tout cette histoire
ouais c'est vrai c'est pas
c'est qu'un parent fidh
si quelque chose cette histoire de 5 qui
va les autres ont des airs et stimule
pour le compteur
vient d'ouvrir samedi quand même ces
matchs devraient être arrêtées à partir
d'un certain écart parce que tout le
monde est maintenant passé derrière
derrière richard apportent non c'est que
lorsque richard laporte y va il va quand
même recette de tenir le plus longtemps
parce que je suis pas sûr qu'il ait
envie de se faire un nouveau bull est
derrière
il y avait 50 50 secondes sans cabaye
n'a pas ça répète
à ouidah et il s'est dit non non non un
autre au curry bon merci pour ta
proposition au club ce qui laisse tomber
quoi ici c'est bon
si besoin et c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que ces matches peuvent être montrés
très long quand tu es dans
sa et
mais bon après on a vu des romans de
talent a donc arrêté
un match il ya un gros écart
c'est pas
l'expression la cagole prend tout son
sens voici à wayne dallas et bien
franchement
quasiment à -10 là sur le score
hallucinant ça y'est de time's up se
terminait donc un atelier dans la partie
mais
il met du coup ça va être terminé
elle répète peut-être pour finir
oui
c'était tout juste avant de repartir
pour
une nouvelle
un nouveau bull est yes alors eu
beaucoup le score 20 le double 1 dans le
golden score 18 9
10 à 9 pour première sarine c'est c'est
complètement incroyable quand même
[Musique]
pas régulièrement faire le double de
points c'est juste hallucinant
dia sarine 17 ans indien 26 60 bon c'est
un très bon espoir
pour le peuple indien
j'ai un rapport quasiment top 10 mondial
c'est un genre qui rigole beaucoup non
plus
donc se prend une
superbe 18,9 c'est impensable pour un
joueur du top 10 passé
mais bon armel leleu format fait aussi
que ces avantages comme tu l'as
soulignait on ira sarine puisqu'il est
vraiment très habituée de ce genre
d'histoire de bullet et c'est donc c'est
aussi normal qu'il s'impose à une
cadence plus lente ça pourrait même
s'inverser sera une autre histoire en
tout cas les règles score et est
particulièrement impressionnant
et donc en tout cas bon malgré
cet écart qui est vraiment énorme
je pense pour en tout cas dans les 2
août 2
deux blessés dont 56 ans était kabyle
hyper serré c'était hyper intéressant et
moi j'ai beaucoup aimé la manière
dont richard rapport à jouer même s'il a
perdu beaucoup de parties l'arrivée de
pas en fait à terminer enfin à
transformer en dire davantage qu'il
avait toutes ses parties mais il rien
offert un beau spectacle dans toutes ses
parties et franchement moi je vais
jusqu'au cou dans les deux joueurs sont
fantastiques et ont de grandes qualités
tous les deux et j'ai beaucoup aimé ce
marché est
en fait on peut résumer stéphane c il
faut prendre l'aventage comme richard à
porte et finir comme yann sarine quoi et
là vous avez vraiment tout c'est ça
c'est ça et or là je pense que si tu
fais ça je pense car si elle n'est pas
les seuls
il peut trembler je pense un
bon voilà donc sinon nous on se revoit
on se revoit du coup je crois lundi à
tous les deux
exact à lundi pour le match digne contre
aronian donc diminue méreau maintenant
il est quoi une euro 4 mondial je pense
nous aurons 3 il est devant un numéro
trois mondial devant carlo n'a pu me
retrouve en défaut par l'oniam qui a
spécifié ces deux tournois de ce format
etc ça va être un match qui qui qui va
être hyper chaud moi je vous dit pièces
rares aux liens parce que je sais qu'il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de ce pitch est
dans sa vie et que il est plutôt bon en
glisse négocié un bing les termes mais
mais du coup en espérant qu'il soit pour
ding pour tous et complices se d'activer
arrêt ça me va s'en va c'est pas un chat
je te la chaleur battez l'oeuf qui moi
aussi c'est comme ce coup à faire sinon
faut pimenter un peu les choses sinon on
va s'ennuyer elle créera un seigneur
plus rien mais j'imagine à la
frustration si tu avais été pour richard
rapporte après je t'entends l'autre tout
le temps de rappeler rfc bizarre qu'on
nous
le dise bon ça fait partie du jeu c'est
saint clair là mais là on arrive à tuer
des raisons que ça il est allé gagner
donc bon on parlera bons amis bons amis
sinon
bah du coup ça il va jouer contre le
gagnant de deux
sauts et
carmona
et donc c'est un gros gros gros match
pour le coup je vois je vois un saut
quand même avec un jeu voit qu'avantage
tôt dans le match
en blitz en toute sûreté sur internet on
a vu rasé quasiment tout le tournoi
pendant le film et cetera je pense que
vraiment il y va on ma part je pense
qu'il est favori et de sueur ce serait
surtout les favoris n'envoie on voit
qu'à roanne abattu ces nouvelles
machines à grave c'est vraiment un
échange 20 ça nous embête donc
normalement pour faire un transfert et
se dire qu'on est derrière caruana aussi
on pouvait faire ça aussi voilà mais en
tout cas je pense que pour charmatz
tsarine contre un des deux américains
déjà là aussi ce sera une paire
intéressant à regarder voire un peu du
secoue bien sa une que peut aller parce
que bac gris tchouk bat rapport et enfin
c'est quand même pas anodin et donc voir
un peu le fruit que ls c'est intéressant
de voir la suite
et on va voir fac et qu'il est vraiment
bien il a et on a vu la mine une grosse
raclée à richard rapport offre donc
maintenant il peut aller il peut aller
très loin
les candidats la gagne takam ans
complètement
yes mort du coup je crois qu'on va on
voit vous abandonnez
donc vous en rendez vous du coup lundi
lundi 6 je sais pas si j'ai le regard
sous les yeux non je n'ai pas l'ardeur
mémoire d'oradour il était 1h de moi
c'est ça donc 15 heures chez moi serait
heures fois je me lève
ça y est c'est donc lundi 15h pour
aronian aronian ding et puis on espère
vous voir nombreux autres cas merci à
tous d'avoir suivi le string et à très
bientôt merci aux intérêts à kevin sympa
merci à tous le chat aussi
yes et la rue une fois promis 100 % vous
aurez vous aurez les caméras vous aurez
tous là on est un petit problème
technique mais mais lundi promis tout
sera nickel et vous aurez droit vous
pourrez voir dit que pleurer en direct
face à
la force de tarot nian
donc donc en tout cas merci à tous du
coup merci encore à toi qui viennent et
on se retrouve lundi à 15 heures sans s
appréciait refait pas bonne soirée à
tous merci thomas o